Hey, you are your take it easy on the aderall. Take it easy on
the aderal. Actually, it's vi dance. Actually, I think five dance.
>> This guy's like bugging the out. Are we watching the
eyes here? >> Have to say my own personal behavior. I agree
with you.
>> Ask people about even the bullet that was fired. How
are you lying about this? >> Shut up, Destiny. >> Shut
up. >> I think that you allegedly secretly recorded during
intimate moments. Destiny, I can't believe anyone. Are you really?
You're embarrassing and you should be shunned from public life
with your disgusting treatment of all sorts of people, including
young leftwing girls, women that you victimized in the
coming from here to I think we watched the two clips.
I think we're just about ready to start with the Piers Morgan
uh the Piers Morgan panel. That's the big content for today.
We're going to do that one. And then there's also the Candace
Owens stream, which is going to be great. >> I'm very excited
for that as well.
Um, oh, what I should do, Wait, hold on. Actually, I shouldn't
start the panel just yet. I got to go through some of the tweets
first. So, >> guys, the tweet we picked out last night
and said that was going to explode. Um, obviously exploded. Obviously
exploded
>> Let's take another look at it real quick >> just
to We'll take another quick look at it. But this is some background
you need going into the PICE panel. All right. So, this is last
night. This is uh Desty's comments on on a Hutch Hutch conversation
with somebody who's coming in and basically saying, "Oh, Bernie's
Bernie's statement where he like disavowed violence was uh Bernie's
statement where he disavowed violence was totally cucked." And
Desi probably agrees with that. Hutch was arguing back against
that. And Desi reacted to it and says specifically this, which
is actually something he said on the Twitch panel. I don't know
how people are having a hard time putting this together. Maybe
it's cuz most people weren't watching anymore, but eventually
he did. He did actually get this out. >> Shout out the
crime statistics.
>> Not not exactly. Like >> I need you need conservatives
to be afraid of getting killed when they go to events so that
they look to their leadership to turn down the temperature. >> It's
a requirement that conservatives feel terrified of violence
so that they p pressure their leadership to turn down the temperature.
Uh-huh.
Dude, the best part about this is I just want to go from this.
Okay, directly from that. I want to scroll down to Okay, this
guy this guy does narrativize it a little bit. Steve Bedell,
also not as he calls for conservatives to be killed more often
so they will be afraid to attend events or speak out. And it's
like, okay, well, he did call for them to basically be they should
be scared, right? But he said so that they pressure their leadership
to turn down the temperature, right?
And so that's that's like
is that the most tangible part of this? Is that what you should
really be like upset about or angry about? No. Not not like sorry
the the last part here where it's like he's not saying to uh
to be afraid of speaking out. It's like so they do speak out
and tell their leadership to turn down the temperature. It's
like a premise but it's fine. There's like a slight deviation
there. I just like that the the two people I follow who had replies
on this are Connor and Dev just with the biggest brooms of all
time, right?
Actually, the exact quote is, "You need conservatives to be scared
of getting killed going to events, so they look to their leadership
to turn down the temperature. I think Steven's way off in recent
commentary, but you should be accurate so as to not get people
yourself." It's like, bro, actually, the thing that gets people
killed isn't the oh to turn down the temperature. It's the part
where he says he wants conservatives scared of violence, of getting
killed.
>> This is like an insane
tweet to do. And it's even more insane that it's basically copy
pasted with dev down
>> I'm telling you, you could tell. Also, did your mic
just cut out? I just heard you say something and then I didn't
hear you through here. >> Okay. No, I thought I heard you
say something in the other room and then I didn't hear it through
my headphones. Anyway, um >> I was coughing.
>> Oh, that's what it was. That's why it didn't come through.
Okay. Uh, and the dev copy paste it. Actually copy paste it.
What what he actually said was, "Conservatives need to be afraid
to go to events so they will look to their leadership to turn
down the temperature. Whether you agree with his actual sentiment
or not, you misrepresented it in your tweet and posted the actual
video debunking yourself." Um, actually, you didn't directly
quote him. >> Actually, you didn't directly quote him.
In fact, in fact, you did not directly quote him. Okay.
>> Yeah. Dev actually doesn't get the quote right, does
he? Hold on. Let's hear it >> Exactly. Like >> I
need You need conservatives to be afraid of getting killed when
they go to events so that they Hold on.
>> He said afraid.
>> Yeah, Dev is right. He said afraid.
>> Uh Dev's not No, Dev didn't say right at all. Not afraid
to go events. They need to be afraid of getting killed. >> Oh,
okay. They both >> getting killed going to events. says,
>> "Yeah, but then Connor says they need to be scared."
Even though Zan said,
>> This is just
>> I don't know. Both these people.
>> Sorry. Uh, got a tweet. That's so goofy. That's just
crazy. I don't I don't even Dude, what are we doing? What are
we
>> I don't He comes in. He comes in to like actually
tone police this guy and doesn't say what the actual quote is.
>> I I don't know. Like I genuinely I hope to high heaven
that all it is is that these guys are like like rents do and
they're in financial like straits and they feel like this is
the best way to make money is farming Destiny's audience because
any other prospect is just significantly like more dire. Like
it's just like or you're like or you're like >> you're
afraid of going down if he goes >> I don't Yeah. Like there's
there's like there's I don't know man. It's crazy. I don't I
don't know what the goal is from these guys. Anyway, so I thought
that was interesting, but you need this uh you need the full
tweet here. I don't actually know what I don't actually know
what else conservatives to be afraid of getting when they go
to events so that they look to their leadership to turn down
the temperature. The issue is right
>> they don't feel like there's any fear. Like I don't
know. I don't know. It's like memes. It's just memes to everybody,
I guess. I don't know, bro. I don't know. I don't care. I'm playing
video games. Okay, I'm done today. I don't give a [__]
God, I'm it's gonna be so gay if I get killed in the next two
months of I'm doing all the out here. Please don't anybody make
any actual the most weak ass speeches on my side. God, if it
happens, holy [__] I'm going to >> It's going
to be so gay. It's going to be so gay and cocked and gay and
cocked and gay. >> He's wearing out speeches for his friends
or if he dies. Does you want to like pre-write people's statements
if he gets killed? What the [__] Why do you care
what people say after you get
>> Wait, hold on. What did you get in the next [__]
two months? >> I misunderstand. Did I [__]
gay if I get killed in the next [__] two months of
[__] I'm doing with all the cuck [__]
out here? Please don't anybody make any actual [__]
the most cucked weak ass [__] [__] ass
speeches on my side. God, if it happens, holy [__]
I'm going to Oh, that is actually what he's talking about.
That's crazy. >> Yeah, he's saying if I die,
start a civil war. Don't try to turn down the temperature, okay?
If I get shot, don't try to turn down the temperature. Don't
do it, guys. That would be crazy. That'd be the worst case >> People
who will for him
anybody's going to follow them. >> If you guys stop the
violence because I got shot, that would be crazy. That's the
last thing I want in the whole >> That'd be so
Don't stop after I Jeez.
>> What? Oh, that's embarrassing. I didn't >> I didn't
even catch that. That's baffling. Uh, how would you characterize
your political position to a new viewer? Um,
man, pretty lived up at this point to be honest. I like I used
to be more populist, more reactionary, and now I've kind of seen
like what that happens and like what the long-term or even short-term
prospects of it are, and I'm like, you know what? I'll just go
back to liberalism for now. I'll wait until we find something
better. I just I've been like scared out of that by watching
how the Trump administration's operated. Okay. It's uh it's not
good. It's not good. No, don't be a li. Be a centrist. I don't
care. I don't care. I don't care. All right. Okay. We've got
we've got the context for the clip. We uh we tweeted a little
bit. We we've done some stuff. We're going to go into
the Piers Morgan panel. Anyway, we've lost Cornell West for now.
Maybe we'll get him back. Um well, Andrew Wilson referred to
Destiny's insane tweets a little earlier, which were disavowed
by Ana Kasparian. Well, Destiny joins us now. Um, Destiny,
you've been quite active on social media since Charlie Kirk's
death. When Erica Kirk posted uh Charlie's coffin, you responded
she tagged him brackets crying face emojis
uh in response to
uh the uh you're like edgy tweets don't work well when you get
like the court the court stenographer reading of them, right?
There you go. like like they always seem worse
at least in terms of like you have to answer for this when when
real actual adults are asking you like why did you tweet this
right and he's got to pick he's got to pick which direction he
goes in is he going to be the joker or is he going to actually
like pretend
Haba's tweet ordering people to fly their flags >> okay
but she tagged him yeah but you no you tag people for other reasons
than them seeing it right
you you know you would tag people so that like people searching
for that person would see the tweet or see the message like the
tag isn't n't even confusing.
You like have to buy into the premise of the joke. You have to
buy into wanting to make fun of her to not understand why she
would tag him. Like you have to kind of be performatively
to not understand why she would tag him in the tweet and make
the joke at all. Half master memory of Charlie. You posted on
X buying flags and poles just to fly them fully erect. And you
then posted yesterday ending every conservative debate call out
I do in 2026 with don't dodge, bro. That's not what Charlie would
have wanted. Um, I mean, do you think that your response to the
cold-blooded murder of Charlie Kirk has been appropriate?
>> Yes. I think that the only way this country moves forward.
>> It's like it's just funny cuz he has I don't know. I
don't even know if he has to do this, but like he has he he like
shows up and he he's just going to try to say like, "No, no,
this was required." And it's like, "No, it wasn't." None of the
stuff is actually required that he's going to talk about, right?
He's going to act like it is. like you can't make the points
he's making without also like avowing violence, without also
painting a target on other people, without also doing all these
things, right? It's uh but it's none of it's required. None of
it is actually required. And he won't make any argument that
shows that it's required at all. Into a better world is when
conservatives can finally realize that they need to turn the
temperature down on their side. We are 10 years into whatever
this Trump madness is and there is not a single mainstream conservative
that will call for a lowering of the temperature on their side.
I think that liberals need to wake up and finally realize that
if they're not willing to do it I think actually didn't didn't
a couple conservatives come out and say like actually Donald
Trump too needs to turn it down. Wasn't that Massie? Was did
Massie do that? I could have sworn some conservatives, some Republican
lawmakers even came out, at least one that I I I'm positive it
was Massie came out and said, "Yeah, we need Donald Trump to
turn it down, too." Like two person. Okay. Well, sorry. I'm referring
to the all claim, not the like every single one claim, right?
Yeah. Unfortunately, the counter example is the disproving of
the all claim, guys. He didn't say three. He didn't say two.
He said there's not a single one. Do it. It will never come down.
If you wanted Charlie Kirk to be alive, Donald Trump shouldn't
have been president for the second term. Every time he's in office,
this happens. People joke. That's
>> Is that even a sensical claim?
If you want Charlie Kirk to be alive, Donald Trump shouldn't
have been in office again. Man, how do I analyze that? Cuz I
guess it's a little nebulous. It's like a little nebulous as
in there's probably some reading of that you could make where
it's not him actually directly calling for violence or saying
violence is okay, right? But like unfortunately like 99 out of
a 100red readings of that statement are just like a direct like
oh yeah you guys want to you guys want to vote for people like
Trump well get is like I could kind of steel man that but what's
the point what's the point in steel manning it if the the average
interpretation is going to be you're just appreciating violence
right now. I don't know realize that if they're not willing to
do it >> isn't it also the idea that his criticism is how
to be better at being violent
which is like unhinged. What do you mean? >> Right. If
he's saying, "Oh, if you didn't want this, it should have been
sooner." Or, "I wish that the person that assassinated didn't
miss. Where was this guy on the day that Trump >> got assassinated?"
Oh, if you guys are going to do war crimes, don't record it on
your phone. Like, he's having a pretty consistent pattern of
not disavowing violence, but like >> telling people how
to do it more strategically,
which is just encouraging and like celebrating it. No. >> Um
I don't know if I interpret it that way, but I think a lot of
people would interpret it that way. Like I've got my way of interpreting
it. It's like a little different, but yeah, I think that's probably
a >> I think that's how basically everybody actually receives
it is like even if even if like things were slightly better.
Is it fair for interpret it that >> Yeah, I think it's
fair. Yes, I think it's fair. >> It's very hard to see
it as a joke when it's like a consistent thing that keeps coming
up and it's not met with any Just kidding. Yeah, there's no there's
no downside. And like he I think he kind of >> there's
no joke.
>> Well, and I think what he will try to do is he'll try
to say, "Well, actually, if you go and watch like my stream,
then technically I said that as long as Trump turns the temperature
down, we will too." And it's like, okay,
but you're you're actually like relying on one, that's blackmail.
Two, like that's not even a dis that's not a disavow. Like it's
it's literally not a disavow. It's not anything. It's you. So
yeah, it's not it's not accompanied by anything here and he just
refuses to do that. He refuses because I think he he understands
like he's looking for the attention. I think that's why there's
no u what do you call like oh I'm just joking or oh I'm just
speaking like aggressively but this is what I mean. There's no
explanation, right? I think that's why he does it is for the
attention as well.
>> Yeah. Do it. It will never come down. If you wanted
Charlie Kirk to be alive, Donald Trump shouldn't have been president
for the second term. Every time he's in office, this happens.
People joked about when Biden came in, it was so boring. Nothing
was going on. Seven out of 10 of the largest protests in American
history have happened under Donald Trump. All of the recent political
violence that's happened in this country over the past 20 years,
the majority of it, the overwhelming majority of it, everybody
gets mad because they keep asking Grock about it, has been conservative.
>> Who shot Charlie Cook?
>> A guy from Utah who was raised in a Christian family.
Uh, it's just it's just like sophistry.
>> The guy described
he didn't have a trans girlfriend. He didn't have any trans influences.
He didn't have any trans bullets. Yeah, I'm sorry. You guys were
wrong on all of >> To be clear, the governor of YouTube
>> He didn't have any trans He literally did have trans
influences. What?
>> He didn't have a trans girlfriend. He didn't have any
trans influences. He didn't have any trans >> The FBI said
today that he had a trans
um trans >> girlfriend. Yeah. Yeah. I just Hold on. >> Transitioned
and was his girlfriend. >> Did he say he didn't have a
>> Utah who was raised in a Christian family who was a
22-y old >> guy described
he had a trans girlfriend. >> Oh, he says he didn't. Hold
on. Steven
>> He didn't have a trans girlfriend. Yeah. >> He
didn't have trans influence in his
>> Yeah. But that's just a lie, right? That's just like
a Well, unless Sorry. Unless like multiple different sources,
not just Cash Mattel, but multiple different sources, up and
down government, up and down investigators, right? There's like
multiple articles with multiple sources now that say the partner
was trans and that was his
>> You would have to You would have to not believe the
federal government. You would not you would have to not believe
the local state government in Utah because it's the governor
in Utah that's saying that they also took these statements and
got this reporting. >> Yeah. You have to go to a level
of distrusting
you have to go through to a level of distrusting
uh institutions that I thought was like totally unamerican like
borders on treasonous almost right now. I don't trust the FBI
like on its own. I don't trust Cash Patel but I do trust like
individual investigators who are providing sources. It seems
like there's a lot of people who are pointing this direction.
I I >> Right. Because you can't have a secret with so many
people with their hands in the pot, right? >> Well, there's
that there's like there's all of the Reddit stuff. There's all
of like dude, there's like so many things going on here.
>> That sort of conspiracy would beg for like so much coordination
that would be unlikely without whistleblowers, loose ends, etc.,
etc. That's usually why there was like this position that yeah,
you should trust institutions because the conspiracy that you're
cooking up in your head is like fantastical if you really consider
what it would take for it to like take off. >> Yeah. It's
like it's insane that all of these institutions could be lying
about this, like totally making it up and nobody's going to step
forward and blow the whistle on this. Not even the guy. Like
the guy isn't going to say, "Hey, like why wouldn't the guy say,
"No, I didn't have a trans girlfriend." And like you guys are
running like not his parents, not anyone. No one's going to step
forward and go, "Yeah, the the other guy the the partner the
partner isn't going to come out and say, "Oh, I'm actually not
trans. Fox News is lying about >> that one." Because they
are saying that the guy isn't cooperating. So they're going to
take that statement and stretch it to mean that all of this other
stuff is not true, which I think we talked about it already.
It seems like the person not cooperating, the suspect not cooperating
means that they're not giving up all of the people who might
have been involved in coordinating or influenced him. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Exactly. But I So yes, and that is a part of why they the
the person would but the partner should say something, right?
You'd think the partner would say something
like there's a million other places you could >> but there's
a Sorry, I'm saying the partner themselves could easily just
say something publicly could easily just say, "Yeah, no, I'm
not trans." Or, "No, no, no, that's not real." Right. But they're
not they haven't done anything like that. I just I find it weird
that the partner wouldn't come out and go, "Oh, people are running
with this for some reason. It's like totally made up." Right?
Wouldn't that have like downside downstream effects if the partner
wasn't trans or gay or whatever. Wouldn't that have like downstream
effects for their personal life having all that misinformation
spewed about them? No. I know Eat Silk songs. I've watched that.
We watch that on stream. I'm just telling you that like I'm just
telling you that like there's there's like 80 different sources
for this information and Destiny's just going I don't believe
any of it. It just seems preposterous to me. That's uh that's
weird. I'm gonna
>> a guy from Utah who was raised in a Christian family
who was a 22-y old guy
He had a trans girlfriend. He didn't have any trans influences.
He didn't have any >> Wait, hold on. You guys are like,
"Okay, I'll just say hold on. Kane 228. I have to actually go
through some chat messages first. I don't think not believing
things around this case isn't crazy with how much misinfo is
going around. Except the misinfo is easily
All of the misinfo that's come out. I can easily go show me any
source on this and and it's gone. Right? Like the the there's
multiple different sets of reporting. You can see Fox News go
from talking about this woman who's reporting it to going we
actually talked directly to the FBI. The FBI has informed Fox
News that this is the case. And I can I can I've watched this
whole thing go along. Like it's >> also he's making definitive
statements here. He's not saying I don't know what to believe.
We don't know this. He's saying he didn't have this. He didn't
have that. There was no transgirlfriend.
He's making definitive claims. >> No. Hold on, Rhox. No.
The ATF did not say the bullets had transit on it. Some
filed away evidence and said, "Oh, it appears to be trans ideology."
That reporting is never meant to be public. the ATF would never
have made that information public. >> It is not an official
statement from the ATF. It was someone who worked with the ATF
that gave like an a bit of info to what was it to was Steven
Crowder one of the people >> and Steven Crowder ran with
it.
>> So it's not like an approved statement. You would say
that that's an employee of the ATF that just like leaked something.
>> Yes. Yeah. It's an employee who leaked stuff. That's
why Steven Crowder got serless subpoena. Yes. Black Irish have
seen that. That is not the only piece of information that says
that he is a trans partner. Multiple people the FBI's in uh interviewed
multiple people. The uh the FBI's interviewed multiple people
and the FBI multiple FBI sources have told multiple news outlets
the same thing. >> I believe Axios had uh multiple pieces
of reporting for the same thing. Oh, the archive link isn't working
now. Can this work? Hello. [__] My archive link isn't
working. I'll try to find this in just a >> But there was
reporting from Axios that was the same thing. Axios.
Yes. Hold on. Kirk investigators, a gas transgender roommate
may lead to motive.
So, it's the what? It's the people like Robinson's transgender
roommate here. Hold on. Um I believe the governor themselves
has come out now and said that the the roommate was transgender.
>> Yes. And that they were dating and that they are not
revealing
they're not revealing much more information because um the partner
has been cooperative. And I think that's like on behalf like
to protect that partner or something. Yeah, I'm about to rage
out in my chat as well. It was to predict the partner. Yes, but
I'm about to rage out. Uh, are you guys stupid? Who are you watching
that you guys don't see the governor come out and literally say
that he lived with a romantic partner who is undergoing a gender
transition? Are you guys stupid? Who do you watch that doesn't
give you this information? Where are you guys going?
Like, where are you guys going for your info that you don't get
any of this? This is crazy. So, a bunch of people here are like,
"There's no way. There's not nothing that shows this at all."
>> Oh, someone said that they watch Hutch. Hutch is his
boy. Okay, >> that's crazy. Did he not live at home? No.
No, he didn't live at home. I'm sorry. I just I listen, I just
don't think the governor would like lie about this. I just I
But whatever,
that's all. That's it. I'm going to I'm going to stop paying
attention to this trans girlfriend. He didn't have any trans
influences. He didn't have any trans bullets. Yeah. I'm sorry
you guys were wrong on all of that. To be clear, the governor
of Utah, Spencer Cox, has made it clear that their investigation
has now established that he had been radicalized by a leftist
ideology which drove him to do this. That's just >> I'm
sorry. Excuse me. When >> yesterday he said that the governor
>> No, no, no. When was he radicalized? In the six months
that that he did remote college. Not >> I don't know when
he was radicalized, but I do know I do know the very reasonable
founding governor of Utah has made it clear that the may want
it. an ongoing investigation.
>> Wait, he No, he has said this directly.
>> The governor could be wrong. The governor could be getting
misled.
>> Maybe the the governor is like could be getting misled,
but the governor said this is fact. The governor understands
how to report things, how to say allegedly. The governor is not
saying allegedly. The very cooperative roommate who is a romantic
partner and trans transitioning. Why would he say that? I the
cope is insane. >> I don't want to hear it, Destiny. But
the the reality is the investigators according to the governor
of Utah have established that he was radicalized to a leftist
ideology that drove him to murder Charlie Kerr. Now let me just
ask
to deal with it accusing the governor of lying. That's your prerogative.
>> Why is he this is at least as bad in the other direction?
No, that you're you're saying okay all of these this is like
this is actually like queuing on again. No, actually those institutions
are all just lying and it's actually untrue. It's actually just
untrue.
It's not It's not that we don't know. It's just untrue. He wasn't
radicalized. We don't know when he was We don't know what's going
on. >> Uh what? But but >> if it turns out to have
been somebody with a leftist ideology who wanted to shut up Charlie
Kirk, would you condemn
>> I won't condemn anything until the president of the
United States can go on air and say all of us need to calm down.
So, you won't condemn the murder of Charlie Kirk until Donald
Trump says >> I'm a YouTuber. Leftists and and Democrats
have been condemning and turning down the temperature, condemning
violence, turning down the temperature for a decade. Donald Trump
can't go on TV and say all of us need to calm down. Can you tell
me why he cannot? >> Why would you expect anybody destiny?
You can't answer that. Can you answer that question? Why can't
you answer this question? All of us should be less violent. Trump
say that
his behavior content on Donald Trump say right now let me let
me ask a question. >> It's a great question from Anakasparian.
Why are you letting Trump be the bar for like moral decisions
in the United States? Right? Like at some point other people
should actually step up and say this is unacceptable. And here's
the thing. If if stepping up and saying Donald Trump is not the
moral paragon, he is not a moral paragon. He should not be leading
this country. If that ideology continues to actually persist
and win, then your country's anyway. Burn the whole thing. You
guys should be in a civil war,
right? If your country is going to go, you know what? Actually,
this guy refusing to do anything. Yeah, [__] it.
Your country is done anyway. Blow it up on Donald Trump.
>> President of the United States of
>> America and the leader of the destiny. >> You
have a huge audience of young men who listen to everything you
have to
It doesn't matter. You have a huge audience and because of the
fact that you have a huge audience, you have a responsibility
to not
it hasn't been broken. You actually care about the country and
want to bring people together. You do the opposite. You represent
the worst of us. Destiny, you're embarrassing. You're embarrassing.
Let me >> has been broken because people bully you on Twitter.
>> That's what he said.
Yeah, that's what he said. Uh what is she so what is she saying
back to him that you have an audience you have a duty you have
an audience of like young men who take what you say very seriously
you can't just go and like spam about >> he's embarrassing
he's like the worst of
like what the online political commentators are right >> yeah
she did get bullied uh I don't think she got bullied by Twitter
as much as she got bullied by um like she tried to go and step
in like the what do you call it the unaligned direction and she
got mocked by her peers I would say that's a bigger deal than
just Twitter. >> you care about the country. You want to
bring people together. You do the opposite. You represent the
worst of us. Destiny, you're embarrassing. You should tell. All
right. Let me ask Donald at once, please. If Donald Trump would
have come out today, we should all be less violent. I have no
problem saying, >> I have one question for you, Destiny.
Why can't conservatives do that? Why can't conservatives do that?
>> Destiny, I have a question for you. Why do you think
in your campaign for everyone to dial down the temperature? Why
do you think that mocking the grieving widow of Charlie Kirk
when she posts?
That's actually a good question. Hey, you're just going to like
post a bunch of unh you when you were um when you were posting
about those kids in Texas dying in the flood because they jerked
off to
Okay. When you were joking about those children, those like 10
to 12 year old kids off to and that's why they got killed by
a natural disaster. How is that you wanting everyone to turn
the temperature down? I don't actually know. Could you explain
how that was wanting everyone to turn the temperature down? Interesting.
>> An image of her at the coffin side. Why do you think
that constitutes
turning down the temperature? >> You can't turn down the
temperature on your own. The president of the United >> You
inflame the temperature. You're mocking his widow. >> Inflamed.
You're mocking his widow. We've had multiple political assassinations
over the past year. What do you mean? It's turning up the temperature.
Did you mock his widow
>> Why does he mock his widow? >> Because she's because
she's being used.
>> It's like it's actually just you need to reiterate every
single time. I want to just point out that every single person
on this Oh, what the why did that go back? Oh, annoying. Um I
don't know exactly where we were. Multiple political assassinations.
I'll find that. But I just want to point out that other people
in the panel and it's doing a great job already. I think everybody's
figured out that this is the tactic. You just sit back and you
continue to be a
right here. So, you sit back, you continue to sound like an adult,
and he spurs the out, right? And he just continues to look like
a child, a spuring child, and everybody else just talks in normal
adult voices the whole time, just speaking your normal adult
voice, and then he looks here. And they're like, why does that
why? Okay, so you should be able to mock Charlie Kirk's widow.
That's like what you want to do. You can't say, "Oh, well, I'll
turn I'll turn the temperature down eventually." And also like
just post totally unhinged rhetoric at the widow of the guy who
got assassinated. You could you could easily just opt out and
say, "Yeah, I don't care. I'm I'm just here for attention if
you wanted to be honest, but >> you can't turn down the
temperature on your own. The president of the United States inflamed
the temperature. You're mocking his widow." Inflamed mocking
his widow. We've had multiple political assassinations over the
past year. What do you mean it's turning up the temperature?
Why did you mock his widow online? Why did you mock his widow?
Because she's because she's being used as a political weapon
right now for conservatives to continue. I just this is like
a great idea of like what the rest of America sees right now.
Unfort as much as it's not a very like representative sample
just like a lot of disgust and like oh so you're not going to
take any responsibility for anything you do. You're just going
to blame it on everybody else and be a petulant child who screams
at people on the internet. Okay, cool. I I think Pobic actually
has managed to hold this space the whole time and now it's finally
appropriate this like somber like gh gross face. Well, I just
want to say she is being used
um by the right, but especially in moments like this by him,
she is being used by the left to imagine that there's another
like there's another enemy. There's another evil of foot. Look
at how how much he's just like carrying the political violence
message. You're give grace to a mourning widow. Like, holy >> Or
I mean, I don't even need him to like I think he should obviously,
right? That's what I tried to do is like I know I'm not going
to like this if I watch it, so I'm not I'm going to shut it off.
>> You just have any sort of ability to look at yourself
in the mirror to see when you say, "Oh, they're using her.
So the are you?" >> Yeah, exactly.
>> She's because she's being used as a political weapon
right now for conservatives to continue their What do you mean?
Wow. She's literally doing her husband just got murdered >> on
email. Yeah. And she's using it to drive up recruitment for >> You
can't even condemn the murder. You won't condemn it. >> You
can't even tell his side. >> So deranged about Trump that
you cannot condemn the >> So Ry says uh
Queen made a good point here that Destiny would want I mean this
is kind of mind reading, but I I I think it's probably true that
if Destiny were in the same situation, he'd want like his widow
to fund raise off of him the same way to keep his political movement
going. I think a lot of people >> He doesn't want to die
a You better keep the fight going. >> Don't out make crazy
statements. Okay, keep the civil war going. Yeah, we see that.
We see that in his message from last night. Don't out for guys.
If I get shot, don't out. Don't do these statements about like
political unity or peace. That >> or civility. >> Why
would anyone want their Yeah. Why would anyone want their death
to be in vain? I don't think it would be in vain if she wasn't
going in quite the direction she was going. I think she could
go, we need to categorically disavow violence and she could do
a lot of things around the disavow of violence, around being
peaceful. She could eliminate a lot of the language around, you
know, the battlecry heard around the world and that people are
going to Yeah, she could do a lot of that. You could easily do
this. >> Yeah, such
Donald Trump off of it. >> Let me bring in Let me bring
in Let me bring in >> Wait, Nyx, why do you think Hold
on, Nyx, you're you're saying something stupid again. Why would
you think Destiny would hate that when he is literally said if
I get shot, don't do speeches like this. Like keep keep saying
what you need to say. He's literally like he's somehow without
a partner actually saying I wish somebody would do this for me.
I wish somebody would keep this fight going for me.
I Yeah, I don't know. But Donald Trump off
Let me bring in Let me bring in Let me bring in sit here and
make money off of it. I mean, that's what we're all doing. I'm
not going to cast the first stone on that one. We're all We're
going to make money off of this. We don't none of us get to go,
"Oh, you're all sitting here making money off of this. You're
all in the same place. You're all doing the same thing." Right?
I I find that a little That's a weird virtue signal right there.
>> World will be there's still no answer to that question,
Pierce. You can't say, "Why can't Donald Trump Why can't Donald
Trump simply go on TV and say we all need to turn it down like
Biden could, like Obama could, like the Clintons could, like
like Kla could? Why not? Why can't you condemn the murder of
Charlie? >> Unbelievable. It's I'm not the
>> So, I have to point out here that this this conversation
should seem shockingly similar to two years ago about the same
time about 2 years maybe 23 months ago. Okay. We watched Hassan
[__] go on a a panel for Piers Morgan and Piers was
saying the same thing. Everybody was saying the same thing. Why
don't you disavow? Why don't you disavow? Right. Why don't you
disavow? Why don't you just f and we we came up with >> we
came up with the condemnation sandwich. Okay, it's the easiest
thing in the world. Condemn very bad thing broadly. Then say
your piece that's like about your political message and why hey
that condemnation is like slightly couched. Okay. And then followed
up with but even though I'm couching it, even though I'm saying
there are some conditions to it and stuff, here's another condemnation.
I I don't think political vi violence works, right? So you say,
okay, you know what? I uh I I condemn the violence. I condemn
the violence against Charlie Kirk. Okay, that being said, I believe
that Donald Trump is pushing us in this direction and I believe
that if I had to blame one person more than a leftist, I would
blame Donald Trump more. But despite that, and I wish he would
bring the temperature down, I wish other people would ask him
to bring the temperature down. But despite that, I still think
it's despicable that this man was attacked for for like while
speaking on a campus, while exercising his First Amendment right.
And I categorically deny or categorically condemn anybody who
seeks to use violence against people like this. Right? It's so
easy. You just do the condemnation sandwich. It's the exact thing.
I don't know how Destiny has managed to change so much on his
uh his tactics and what he expects from people. If it's Hassan
[__] speaking about or speaking about Palestine or
speaking about like some group that's doing terrorism on behalf
of Palestine, oh, he understands this perfectly. He understands
how how Hassan's up everything, right? He understands it perfectly.
But when it's him and it's like his pet thing that he's upset
about and emotional about, he can't see reason. He can't see
anything. He doesn't get it. It's a little It's like strange
to me that I would love to go back at some point, maybe take
a look at what his statements were around Hassan not wanting
to condemn and Hassan not wanting to condemn the Houthies, right?
Cuz it's the same thing. Oh, in front of you, you guys don't
even want to try to fix the problem, right? You don't want to
fix the problem. You're not interested. You just want to distract
me. The real problem is this. The real problem is the genocide
in Palestine. The real problem is Donald Trump's rhetoric. It's
like, well, I I could I could be a little bit sympathetic to
that. Uh, imagine I said Hassan is bad a whole bunch of times.
Hassan is bad. Hassan is bad.
Hassan is bad. Okay. >> Hassan is good.
>> All right. So, but he can't I don't know what happens
that he just gets so emotional. He can't see it. He is like a
child. He can't see what he has to say. But everybody knows why.
I remember there was like a black woman who was on the panel
with Hassan for the October 7th stuff and it was the same guy
or sorry, it was the same. Sorry, it was the same. It was not
the same guy. It was the same issue. She went, she con she condemned,
then she said, "But here's the whole issue with Israel." And
then she condemned again. It's like, it's so easy to understand.
You just move through that way and it's like then you're you're
golden. There's no reason not to condemn it. Especially when
it's like in line with your principles. You don't think political
violence is good. I mean, or you know, it's starting to look
the other way with Destiny. Like maybe he actually does
actually care about um or maybe he actually wants political violence.
Yeah. So anyway, >> you condemn the murder of Charlie Kirk.
>> Unbelievable to me. >> Why can't you condemn the
murder of Charlie Kirk? >> Because it wasn't my side that
caused it. It should be driving up. >> It actually was
your side that caused it. It was your side. >> This guy
was raised in a white Christian
ideology radicalized by leftism at all. You have no proof of
that whatsoever. the investigation
was a conservative just like the people that fired bomb Shapiro's
house was a conservative just like all the J6ers were conservative
just like the Proud Boys were conservative every single one of
these every single one of these people oh was Jack Povic what
the author of Unhuman another person that uh that uh Charlie's
good one dude >> I'll give Oh dude this guy at least when
he was like
I dude it's it's yeah sorry this is the exact He's like so washed
up that like he's just got nothing. He's like so emotional. He's
lost the plot entirely and he just like faltered entirely. It's
Jack Pobic. He's the guy who like smurfed on Twitter because
he's too embarrassed to say his real political opinions, right?
He's the guy, didn't he run uh he didn't run libs of TikTok.
He ran some other fake account, right? Like there's so many things
you could say about Jack Pobic.
I He just like floundered and wokeness. Yes. Sorry, I cut you
off, Sherry. What were you going to say? >> Nothing. I
was just thinking about that time that he talked [__]
and was like walking through someone
walking through to someone like
in what order do they eat a tide pod? And I just thought that
was so funny. Where' that version go? >> Yeah. I don't
know what happened to the the guy who could be funny. It's like
totally missing. It's totally gone. It's crazy. He's like he
like doesn't exist anymore. That person who used to be funny,
who used to be capable of like actually dunking on people seems
to have entirely disappeared.
What if that was like a stolen joke? >> You think he had
like writers working for him and those people left and now? Yeah.
I mean that seems >> all the funny people around him are
gone and this is sad. >> I don't know. I don't know, man.
It's >> not really sad. I don't give a [__]
>> Yeah, it's not really sad. It's like kind of somebody
getting their >> just fire
house was a conservative just like all the J6ers were conservative.
Every single one of these >> Oh, list mode by the way.
Just like the Proud Boys were conservative. I don't like what
are you even I don't he like when he gets into that list mode
you just have to watch like after the first one the rest of the
points are always just totally stupid. But he's usually speaking
fast enough that he can like get them all through. I don't even
think he's speaking fast enough anymore. Also this is uh that's
going to have to go. That's the jaw the jaw [__]
going on. You know sometimes you just freeze frame and it's it
works pretty well. Yeah. All of their faces all of their faces
are the same. Dude, every single one of these people Oh, it's
Jack Persobic. What? The author of Unhuman? another person that
uh that uh Charlie's put a good one, dude. >> Well, I'll
give you one last chance, Destiny, to condemn the murder of >> Yes,
you are acting like a >> Why can't I hear Donald Trump
violence? All right, you won't hear it. Okay, we've all heard
insane. We've all heard you repeatedly refuse to condemn it.
>> You heard Donald Trump refuse to condemn. There's a
reason the leftists on YouTube are a bigger deal. >> Yeah.
What's incredible is you don't have the basic humanity to condemn
it. You'd rather taunt his widow. I find that sickening. Jack
Pobic. I find it sickening that when people are getting killed
in the country, the president of the United States on Fox and
Friends when they're begging him, what do you say to your followers
that want revenge? He says, I don't know. All the elections are
rigged. It's the radical Democrats. That's insane to me. And
then and then the fixation is, well, who on Twitter and YouTube
isn't condemning the violence. All right, Jack,
you you have you have a great example here of the type of cancer
I'm talking about where when you present direct information they
refuse, they obfiscate. They refu they say it's not true. They
lie. Uh you could see from the bullet. >> Oh, so the end
wokeness thing is not Jack Pobic. Okay. Well, it's a good it's
a good thing. It's a good thing that he didn't bring it up then.
I don't I don't know. There's just probably so many ways. Why
don't you make fun of this guy like me and meing and looking
like he's going to cry into the camera the entire
postings you can see from everything out there that you know
it's it's very clear what happened here u this is the same people
who supported President Trump almost getting assassinated twice
last year Cory Captorii being assassinated last year in in a
situation uh again see just just lies all they do they talk over
they don't even let you give a chance to speak and something
needs to be done >> one hippie dude was not a conservative
I like with both of the people who shot at Trump, I think they
were both like like mentally deranged. I don't think calling
them conservative or liberal or anything really makes sense to
be honest. But
um
like I also think that this person you might not know what leaning
maybe they just like trans who knows why they didn't like Charlie
Kirk like really their ideology
to me doesn't matter as much. Like I feel like everyone's got
to bring the temperature down like first as a primary thing.
But for a political influencer, it is really important to push
an us versus them narrative cuz that builds you a strong cultlike
following.
>> That will see you through thick or thin,
>> I mean, that's what you're financially incentivized
to do. It just hurts the entire like the social fabric. It just
like harms the It's literally improving your own monetary status
by harming the social fabric directly. But yeah, really wish
that wasn't monetized so heavily in so many places. Be great.
Uh, I haven't seen the disprove on that or I haven't seen the
uh,
so people are saying the end wokeness thing got debunked. I have
not seen that. So if anybody wants to link that, maybe we take
a look after >> Absolutely needs to be done. This ideology
should be shamed, humiliated, driven from the public discourse.
I mean, you've got people who have completely dissociated with
humanity because all they care about are clicks and YouTube streams
and likes. Go
to the casket. Go to the grave site. Go talk to the widow. You
know, I I I I don't even know how to how to discuss this with
someone who's completely lost all touch with reality. >> Yeah.
I mean, Jack's answer to why can't the president say we should
>> I'm sorry. You think this person is out of touch with
their humanity now? You want them to go to the the funeral, the
casket, the graveyard to his wife.
>> No. Tell him to stay home.
>> All be less violent. >> The [__] >> Right.
because you can't even condemn the cold blooded >> turns
on death. >> I don't think you're in a position to demand
anything from anybody >> on YouTube.
>> That's not even remotely an argument. It's a complete
nonsequiter. Makes no [__] sense at all. This guy
just throws out this guy is so cooked. I think this was what
happens when you like start falling off um like he used to have
people who come in and argue and set him on the right course
and I think he doesn't have any intelligent people who watch
him and like set him on the right course anymore. And now he
sort of still believes he's like a smart guy who had all those
opinions himself and it just isn't working. So you can see all
the bravado there. It's like almost how I thought of Andrew Wilson
for a long time. I I still think of Andrew Wilson like this that
there's just like a lot of bravado there. >> Sure. Yeah.
>> Yeah. This is the people around him, right? Like I don't
I don't have to live these morals to preach it to other >> There
are a lot of people who have argued his ability to do so. >> Oh,
that's a great point. Right. >> True morals theory. Oh,
that's like a fantastic point that they go, "Oh, well, I don't
need like I don't need him to believe the things to make the
best arguments." And it's like, well, actually, you kind of do
cuz if the people who are giving him the good arguments go away
and you've built this guy up and he's got a huge following, there's
going to be a whole bunch of people who are following this guy
and he's basically like a he's he's like a ship navigator who's
had his eyes poked out for years and somebody else reading the
charts for him and then the other guy like falls overboard and
he's gone now. And Desessie's guiding the ship with no idea of
anything that's going on. He doesn't have any way to navigate
himself. He had other people to navigate him. And now he doesn't
have the morals that push him in that direction. He just made
the arguments.
You've got somebody who's like, you got somebody who's massive
and has no idea how to come to these like uh these positions
or these understandings on his own. He like doesn't get it. That's
crazy. >> So, I'm going to take my uh position. >> No,
it's not telling at all. Luna is is Lun I I don't know how to
say your name. Luna. Okay. It's not literally all they want is
that it's the same thing and everybody understood this. I'm telling
you, everybody understood this when it was Hassan [__]
I'm not going to I don't want to take anything you say seriously
until you condemn. Will you condemn him? Will you condemn him?
It was the same meme, right? And the whole time I'm sitting here
and I'm like, yeah, all we have to do is is you just say the
civilians is bad. You you could even go into specifics and say,
well, I condemn like I don't condemn, you know, the civilian
administration. I think that unfortunately condemning broadly
like I condemn the Alcasm brigades who carried out the operation.
I condemn anybody who's willing to harm civilians. Right? You
could do like a more specific thing, but when you refuse to when
you refuse to condemn the complete like something that is completely
morally black, there is no possible way to defend the the attack
that happened and you are going to refuse to condemn it, you
look unhinged. You look bad basically in every circumstance.
You cannot do that and look good. And somebody needs to tell
these people this. I don't know if they I don't know if it's
the ego that drives them to say like, "Well, no, I can make this
point. I don't know what lets them make it. I actually don't
>> to condemn anybody for anything. You You won't condemn
a cold bloody murder. >> President of the United States.
He's the president of the United States. No one here can answer
that question. >> Basic humanity says the murder was
to be less violent.
Over a decade say the murder was horrific. And >> unfortunately,
the other thing that you got to think about is um to every normie
to every person watching this, nobody's going to say Piers is
unhinged. It doesn't prove anything except that the monetary
the monetary incentive is on peers to just keep asking Destiny
to try to be a human being and watch Destiny refuse to be a human
being. That's where the monetary incentive is. So you're not
even proving that like these people are too unhinged to ever
disavow Trump or say that Trump not disavowing violence is bad.
You're not proving that. You're proving that they can clip farm
you being a totally unhinged lunatic on their stream on their
their panel. That's literally all you all you're proving is that
you're too much of a to understand that they're farming you.
That's the only thing you can prove. You're not proving a good
point. You're not making any intelligent point at all. Oh, look.
They they refuse to actually do it. >> Democrats look terrible,
though. That's what you are doing. >> You are assassinating.
Okay. You are horrifyingly assassinating any Democrat credibility,
any anything positive in terms of Democrats. Okay. You're just
you're destroying it. He is a Republican operative. That's that's
basically where we've come to at this point. This guy is driving
turnout for the Republicans in every election. Incredible. >> Can't
Donald Trump say it
here any words for Donald Trump. >> Donald Trump and nothing.
Exactly. >> Anakas Baron. This to me this is what I'm talking
about that I think there is an element of the left, the hardwoke
left that have completely lost their minds.
If you are not able to just outright simply condemn the murder
of Charlie Kirk and if you cannot stop yourself from mocking
his grieving widow, you are sick. As I've just seen from Destiny,
it's a sick thing. >> Weaponizing a widow's grief to try
to do recruitment for your political party. That's probably one
of the most disgusting things I've ever seen. She's showing up
in emails for recruitment drives for TP USA.
What is your
What did you think the outcome was going to be?
What did you think the >> By the way, are you asking for
the I >> That is a great question. What What did you think?
You think she was going to go, "Oh, my husband's dead." I think
I think the most important thing right now is is letting his
organization wither while I grieve. I think that's actually what
I should do. Like, no. There's a lot of like a lot of the ways
people grieve, okay, there's a very standard grieving process
is to put yourself into your work or to to try to find something
that you can do that gets your mind off of things, right? Perhaps
for her it's continuing to move her co her husband's company
forward. That's the way she's coping with it, right? That would
make total sense. There's a ton of people who do that. That is
like an entirely human process that of course entirely eludes
>> And there's this um there's like this desire to not
want to appear weak, to not want to appear like they got one
over on you. Did you think you were going to hurt me? Did you
think that you were going to just end everything about the man
that I love? Uh you want to show strength. You want to show like
you are
you're not torn down. Your spirit's not broken. Yeah. It just
it makes complete sense if you have a soul. >> Yeah. It's
it just doesn't seem like anything uh it doesn't seem like anything
you can um you can actually like criticize her for. Like yeah,
she's fundraising for his thing. Yeah. I unfortunately she's
just going to do that. She doesn't want her husband's memory.
That's the thing that carries her husband's memory. She doesn't
want her husband's memory to die. You're you're behind
dance. Actually, I think rhymance. >> Wait. Yes. Also,
Rhino Hogs. Yeah, the casket is cringe. It is cringe to post
those videos, but I'm saying the things he listed about like
the funeral or the fundraising and stuff like I would expect
her to do that. Anyway, just Anakasbury is such a queen. What
a queen. That's a That's a critical hit, by the way. That's a
critical hit. That's That's crazy. That's a critical hit right
there. >> Hey, you're asking about take it easy on the
aderall. Take it easy on the aderall. And let me answer the question
that Pier asked. >> You must have been really bullied today.
I guess my behavior.
My behavior is not
>> I I don't know what possessed him to keep going after
after she went with the aderall thing. That's her. If I have
Destiny's accusations, what I hear when I hear that is, "Hey,
you got a lot of worse that I could bring up, but I'm going to
do this one to back you off of being an unhinged lunatic to me,
okay? So, shut the up and let me talk, right?" And apparently,
he keeps going after her. But >> I'm I'm noticing Pierce
Morgan decide to chime in like, "Let Anna speak. Let Anna speak."
Like, oh no, she's spitting here. Let her speak. >> Let
Anakas burying Cook.
>> I think you need to go after Piers. He's throwing shots.
Take it easy on the aderall. And let me answer the question that
Pierce asked. >> You must have been really bullied today.
My behavior is not reliant on how anyone else behaves. Every
morning I wake up and I make decisions about how I choose to
react or respond to things. I don't wake up in the morning, check
what Donald Trump has to say, and then base my own personal behavior
on his behavior. I agree with you in that it would be very helpful
to have the leader of this country, >> dude. How is this
this guy's like bugging the out? Are we watching the eyes here?
>> Check what Donald Trump has to say and then base my
own personal behavior on his behavior. I agree with you in that
it would be very helpful to have the >> This guy's bugging
the out. >> What is he looking at? >> I don't know.
This guy's bugging out, >> Leader of this country want
to turn the temperature down and he hasn't done that. I agree
with you on that. But that doesn't change the way I choose to
respond to what's going on. The idea of mocking a woman who is
now a widow with two young children who witnessed her husband
get shot in the neck and bleed out to death. What's wrong with
you? I just don't understand it. >> That's it. I don't
understand it. I don't understand you, Destiny. You have so much
hatred in your heart. And at the same time, >> it's such
a simple thing. If you're going to weaponize somebody's grief
against the other party, well, then of course people have a right
to fight back against it. I think that she has every right to
grieve in whatever way she wants, but when that grief is going
to be weaponized to do recruitment, political recruitment and
further radicalization of the other side, then of course
>> I mean, couldn't you go ahead? >> No, I'm sorry.
This is incorrect. What you're supposed to do is shut it down
in a way that does not add fuel to a fire. The same way you would
hope Well, you couldn't do it, but when somebody shoots Charlie
Kirk, I don't say, "Oh, he deserved it." kind of like the things
that he said was insane. No, violence is not okay. I'm sorry.
Is this grieving widow saying things that upset you? There's
a way to engage with that without mocking her. Like, oh, it's
really gross that the people around her are using her as a weapon.
>> Yeah, exactly. And he I mean he clearly doesn't understand
this cuz he didn't understand it with Trump either, right? He
did the same thing with Trump. Like he he decided that he was
going to lean into the thing. And it's like there's a there's
a way to not let them drive uh their political movement off of
it to just to contend with that without going to the point where
it's like you have to cast away your humanity to mock somebody.
And >> but he presents it like the only thing I could possibly
do was make fun of her.
>> What do you want me to do? >> After she was crying
over that casket, I had to laugh at her. It was literally I I'm
sorry. What do you want me to do? I had to do it. >> Democracy
depends on it. >> Democracy requires me mocking this widow
right now. I don't know what to tell you guys. Right. And by
the way, I can I can be on the page of like, >> okay, I
don't think anybody should be cancelled for mocking her or mocking
Charlie. I actually don't think so. I don't think you should
lose your job for that. I I think it's like unhinged. >> But
yes, it should be social condemnation. And like if there are
like people who do comedy on the internet, I don't care like
that. Let them have their opinion. If you want to be taken seriously
as a political advocate, you probably don't want to throw yourself
in with those people, right? Who are doing jokes about this grieving
widow or whatever the you can do them. I don't have like condemnation
for people doing them. I'm just saying I think probably you don't
want to be, you know, you shouldn't be the person who's speaking
for the Democratic party or trying to drive Democratic turnout,
right, and be doing those things because I think you're you're
just a >> you're like a recruitment poster for the other
side. You're like not helpful to that process whatsoever.
>> Yeah. Anyway, you not only have the ability to mock
it, I think you have the obligation to mock it. It's insane.
>> Let me He literally said it. >> You You have to.
Those are fascist tears. You don't understand. >> You have
the ob you are obligated to mock anybody crying over a fascist
dying. Guys, you're obligated. You have to. You have to. You
don't have a choice. That guy got gunned down in front of his
kids. I have to laugh at that. I don't have a choice. >> Here.
She sheds is another trans person that's going to die in the
future if I don't tease her.
>> He understands. >> Let me understand your argument.
>> Sorry. I need to pause for a second. Uh, he's saving
trans people right now. Jerry, you're right. He's just saving
them all.
you have the obligation patriot
>> further radicalization of the other side then of course
you not only have the ability to mock it but you have the obligation
to mock it it's insane >> let me understand let me understand
your argument so since others are using her grief to politically
recruit you think that it's okay to mock her specifically >> since
others are using her grief she's the one who gave a 17-minute
speech on TV where she talked about good versus evil she's the
one showing up in TV USA
Let me explain something to you. If someone assassinated my husband,
if someone assassinated my husband, I would not be able to have
the level of composure she had during that speech. I would be
out for blood. I understand why she's angry and why she said
the things that she said. Okay? You need to understand what being
a human is. What it's like to actually lose someone that you
love, that you chose to spend your life with, that you chose
to raise children with. a person who was violently and viciously
assassinating.
>> This is unfortunately this is a fantastic way to to
just attack him for like anybody who actually wants to do mainstream
politics, right? >> Yeah. Yeah. And I I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty sure he has chat GPT up on another monitor giving
him instructions on how to sound like a human being, but I don't
think he's been able to read it fast enough or give them or get
the prompts fast enough to react to Anna.
>> Amazing. I I do you think he gets the chat JP? Do you
think he like makes it like you think he got somebody to set
it up for him so it looks like chat? So even when he's offline
doing this, it like comes through as like chat messages basically
and it automatically types >> just like emulates. Yeah.
Yeah. >> Like that. This is why I've moved away. >> And
when something Yeah, I know. You got bullied online. It's so
funny. It's so funny that you just said that you don't think
about how other people act to define your behavior. Your entire
political ideology now is somehow defined by the people that
were mean to you on Twitter. Nobody cares about somebody who's
grieving. You tell that person. You tell that person
for a couple of weeks.
>> Oh, I can't believe. Maybe you're a little emotional
right now. Maybe you need to take a little time off. Maybe you're
like kind of embarrassing.
Dude, the projection here is actually nuts for him to like try
to flip this on her. Like I feel like I feel like Destiny's relaying
to me what like counterpoints and Aerodite and a bunch of people
have said to him. I feel like he's projecting that onto her right
now. 100% about somebody who's grieving and you tell that person.
You tell that person
for a couple of weeks. It's not about treated like a camera mass
recruitment for our political party while everyone over here
is >> I will say though that is probably what I would say
for advice as well is like and and then I'd say it's incumbent
on people who are influencers not to just take everything she
says and run with it. Right. Yeah. So you're saying that of Charlie
Curse Widow. It's like, hey, that advice would go well with a
couple of different people right now. There's a guy next to Piers,
that's Jack Povic. So, Bucks. Yeah. >> Calling for civil
war. It's unhinged. When you've got people like Matt Walsh of
the Daily Wire, the president
said he'd be okay with his own parents getting if they went to
that Trump rally where that assassination >> and we're
talking to a woman who went on and did the whole conservative
media outlet with Glenn Beck and had nothing bad to say whatsoever.
I know where your bread is murdered. I know what your
at all. That's great. I also had a conversation with Jack and
he was awesome. That's what democracy is about having an exchange
of ideas comes out of his mouth. >> All right, let me bring
in let me bring in agree with him on everything but at least
we can have dialogue and you're completely dude Anna's like actually
just winning. I think it's uh
I think >> also it's amazing that she just has a lot of
my beliefs. I knew I liked her for a reason. >> Here, let
me look at this as well. You like her because she's shares a
lot of your beliefs. I think in some ways I think you would never
do the thing that uh that she I don't I think she does a lot
of something that you can't do. Okay. And that's when somebody
says something and she's sitting there. I don't think she could
bite I think she bites her tongue sometimes.
>> You think she bites her tongue? I feel like she's stupid
face too. >> I think she bites her tongue in like those
interviews with some of those other people. Yeah. I think so.
>> Oh [__] Found a white woman she likes. I
have found a white woman I like. Anna is not a white woman. She's
just a white passing woman. You bigot.
>> Moonray Murray said you would never tell a leftist to
not utilize a death to benefit the party. Uh yeah, I would I
would say hold on. I would say you could totally use that to
fund raise or to to recruitment drive for TPUSA. I don't mind
her doing that. It's it's the rhetoric around violence, the revenge
that she's been talking about, right? That's what I'd be more
concerned about. And I would say it's incumbent on people not
to take that seriously, not to puff her up with that. Like not
to go, "Oh, that's great when you use that." like to say, "Hey,
maybe you could pull back a little bit on that." I think it's
incumbent on the people who aren't as emotionally involved around
her to say, "Hey, that's probably not the direction you want
to go because because that's not what Charlie would have wanted.
It's not what anyone would have wanted." Yeah. Anyway, that's
Sorry, I had to answer that one question from back >> That's
what democracy is about having an exchange of ideas. It comes
out of his >> All right, let me bring in agree with him
on everything, but at least we can have dialogue. >> Anna,
you're completely right by the
didn't it? I and like everybody's going to share this opinion.
Like just act like a human being. By the way, I can fully understand
and say that I don't think Piers would say this around some other
people. I don't think he'd say, "Oh, like harshly condemn." And
I don't think he'd hold people's feet to the fire quite as bad
if it was a leftleaning person who got shot, right? But I think
you also have to understand how big the the Charlie Kirk story
is versus I guess the Minnesota lawmakers as well, right? What
did he just say?
Sorry. That is that is all to say like you have to reinforce
it now in a way that you should have reinforced it before and
I think I would have like obviously political violence is awful.
But I think you have to reinforce it now with this person seeming
to be like of sober mind. They they made this shooting. It wasn't
a mask. It was just them going after the one guy, right? I think
I think you have to be very clear in this moment.
>> All right, let me bring in a
>> Oh, we had a we had kicks. Hold on. 500 kicks from sin
signal. Rage quit. Thank you very much. Send signal for the 500
>> 550. Damn. 560 now. >> Let's go. >> Let's
go. >> What happens when they do a hype train? Is it going
to be like a getting jumped or something? >> I don't know
if you can go from to a curb stomp.
>> I don't think so. What do kicks do? It's just money.
It's like bits. It's a way to donate,
which is kind of nice cuz um kick didn't really have a way to
do tips. Although, I will say right now, guys, I don't think
you can send custom messages. I don't think they come through
to like uh the bot at all. So, I have no way to display them
on stream. So, if you do kicks, they they got to go through chat
and I could possibly miss them, just so you know. All right.
I uh I have to >> Did he do that sound? Sophia, did you
make a
Did you make that kind of sound?
>> I don't know.
>> I don't. Maybe I did. >> Did you do that to getting
the sub? You might, Sophia. I think he's picking up my mannerisms
that I have picked up from Cardi B. >> I got to pull it
back cuz I got to use the bathroom really quick because I've
just finished like all of my caffeine that I brought into my
room. So, I'll be right back. I pulled it back about 60 seconds
cuz I don't want to miss anything. I'll be right back. I'm just
going to hit play or or you could just Why don't you just talk
to chat maybe >> or up to you?
>> Okay. I'll be right back. Give me two >> Do the
real Cardi B sound though.
Oh, Cherry. How's life? Uh, it's pretty rough. Very rough. I'm
not going to lie. Everything tastes different here. Everything
tastes The chocolate is different here. If you are American,
do you know what a whooper is? Whoopers. It's like
this malt chocolate covered ball thing. They have something called
malt teasers here. They're not as crunchy. The chocolate tastes
better here, but they don't have as much
Yeah, whoopers. Why is everyone saying whooper? Yeah, whooper.
Cherry, can you denounce? Can I denounce what? You guys are denounce
JTO's violent.
[__] you guys are typing too much. I know. I'm not
going to denounce that. Oh, is Whooper. Is it the same as Whopper
like from Burger King? I thought you just have to say them different.
Like Whopper is the burger. Whooper is the candy. It is just
like a Whopper. Then how do people know that when you're talking
about, "Oh, I want a Whopper." How do you know you're not talking
about burger? Mars bars for the win. I I think it's Cbury. Cambury
chocolate tastes so creamy. Like the milk chocolate here just
tastes better. What the
did America do? That's British. They I don't have that chocolate
in America, I don't think. Cadbury is sold everywhere. I've only
ever had it here. >> I am back. Hello.
>> Welcome back. How do I like the Dota game? It looks
very similar to League. So I I don't mind watching Dota. Okay,
we're back. Destiny versus Anakasparian on Charlie Kirk's widow
doing like fundraising off of his death. Recruitment for our
political party while everyone over here is calling for civil
war. It's unhinged. When you've got people like Matt Walsh of
the Daily Wire, the president
said he'd be okay with his own parents getting if they went to
that Trump rally where that >> and we're talking to a woman
who went on and did the whole conservative media outlet with
no reason and had nothing bad to say whatsoever. I know where
your bread is murdered. I know we had another >> Anakas
Baron's bread is buttered by acting like a normal human being
with people. Shocking.
Very shocking. Crazy. >> I also had a conversation with
Jack. It was awesome. That's what >> Okay, I will say Anna
has done her like politically online thing and she probably should
call some people out on some of their beliefs a little more than
she does. She's probably a little too nice, but like honestly,
I'll take somebody being a little too human versus being like
0% human. Okay. At least I can just call Anakasparian like stupid
when she says something stupid. I don't think she's like actively
harmful. I I kind of don't think so. I maybe some people argue
when you normalize those other people it's bad, but I honestly
think you just disagree with their points. I think >> democracy
is about having an exchange of ideas comes out of his mouth.
>> All right, let me bring in Let me bring >> I don't
agree with him on everything, >> Jack Pobic POV Jack Pobic
POV after getting called a Russian shill who who only takes who
just lies for Russia. Jack Pobic. He's got the same face he's
had on the entire time refusing to speak. Great update. Great
update from Jack Poic. Okay, >> can we can we just bring
up another just amazing point to why Andrew is so dumb for
pointing at Anna and being like, "You're one of the leftists.
You did this." Like, Anna is one of the people from TYT that
was called transphobic for
what what even happened there? Somebody got fired or somebody
got let go and then they decided to say all of TYT is transphobic
and she got in those crosshairs. Do you remember that? >> Um,
yeah, I remember it. I I do remember it. Yeah. Why did you want
to ask something about it? It was the It was the Benny person,
wasn't it? That that crazy Benny person whose laugh is like Loner
Box's donut sound. >> I can't even remember the laugh now.
>> Yeah, their laugh was crazy. I think if you're if you're
on the side that thinks, oh, the extremist trans people uh on
like on the leftist side are the ones who did this shooting,
it's pretty bizarre to say, Anna, you did this. >> It is
bizarre to do that. And not only that, like one, it was stupid
for that reason, okay? But two, it's also stupid because Anna's
literally doing his job right now. Andrew just gets to sit back
and watch.
Andrew's supposed to be the person who like slays Destiny.
>> Yeah, exactly. This is like the second time and Andrew
just sits this one out. >> How must it be for Andrew Wilson
that like he's been getting his ass kicked by Destiny for like
four or five, six years now, just over and over again, losing
debate after debate after debate. And Destiny's finally like
down and out. He's not getting like quite the same like, you
know, crowd rush he used to. And you have to watch Destiny get
absolutely curb stomped by Taylor Ren and Anna Kasparian back
to back. And you've never beaten them. >> You say nothing.
No, no, not that you've never beaten them. the when you have
so much on him, you say nothing. I want to know what kind of
blackmail does he have on you, Andrew? Because I only I only
ever seen Andrew Wilson back off of topics like this or back
off from debates like this for one other reason, and that was
to prevent heat coming. And I thought it was admirable.
>> It was admirable in that case, but >> we don't
have to bring it up. It was admirable that he did that. It's
bizarre to continue to see him do that. I've only ever seen him
mock Pixie in this
>> That's true. Yeah, that's true. >> Anna, you're
completely right, by the way. Anna is completely right, didn't
>> And the irony of Charlie. >> Wait, what did he
say about Charlie? >> Anna, you're completely right, by
the way. Anna is completely right, didn't >> And the irony
dialogue sure is helping. It helped Charlie, didn't it?
>> I Okay, what's the point there? What What is the goal
of making that point? If you think dialogue is useless, why are
you on this show? I >> It's It's like actually so stupid,
Rhox. It's No, it's it's actually Sorry, we know exactly why
this is. It's not because Destiny didn't go hard on the Gorit.
Uh cuz you look stupid doing it. It's because Destiny uh is everything
Andrew Wilson wants in a leftist. Like he is the exact leftist
Andrew Wilson wants to exist on the internet so he can point
and say, "Look at how bad these people are. Look at look at who
these people are. This is the face, right? He wants he wants
this stupid [__] face to exist on the internet so
he can constantly point to it and all the degenerate he does
all of the li all horrible arguments the spur gang right he wants
to be able to point to this immature manchild and say you like
not but more subtle [__] you not just you this is
who it is this is who we uh this is who we want we want this
guy to be the face of the left yeah that's that's what they want
man >> of Charlie Kirk is that he led the way in in going
in to debate with people who hated him and he would try and have
respect. Charlie beat up on college students unlike you. Let
me bring Andrew Wilson in.
>> I think that's probably true. I don't think Charlie
Kirk looked for like hard debates to win. I don't think he looked
for the best debaters. I don't think he looked for the best clashing
of uh of ideas. I think he mostly just looked to beat up on college
kids and get like dunks and do do his Twitter clips or his Tik
Tok clips. I think that was mostly what Charlie Kirk did. The
idea that he's like some sort of like goatated interlocutor who
sought out the toughest debate opponents and wanted to show that
his ideas were the best. That's just not true. Uh and Andrew
Wilson in his heart of hearts knows that's not true, too. So,
it'd be shocking to see him like really push back on this that
hard. He did go to Oxford to debate. Yeah. So did Hassan, didn't
he? That Hassan also went to Oxford to debate. I don't think
those Oxford debates are necessarily the best >> Gave a
speech, right? >> Oh, he just gave a speech. I see. Yeah.
Yeah. Sure.
>> Let me bring in Andrew Wilson. >> So do you. You
beat up on college students. You go on a college tour. You're
going on a college tour right now to beat up on college students.
>> What are you talking about, Destiny? That's what you're
doing right this second is going on a college tour to go beat
up on college students. By the way, can I just ask you a question
or exclusively beat up on college?
Can you actually answer it? Hang on. Calm down. I just got one
question. I got one question for you and I want you to actually
answer it. Are you glad Charlie Kirk is dead? >> No. I
don't think anybody in this country should be dying to political
violence. It's insane. the past 5 years in this country. >> It's
insane. It's totally insane. >> It's been crazy. But the
reality is until conservatives
that Trump deserves to do it. Why did you tell them that? >> To
say until conservatives have to say, "Hey, we all need to be
less violent." There's no purpose in Democrats doing it because
every time Democrats disavow, you further entrench your guys'
delusional beliefs. He's like this is a actually this is like
a microcosm of this exact argument is a microcosm of the problem
we were saying the brain drain problem. The person who gave him
this idea that you don't disavow that you don't go to this extent
was Josiah. Josiah is not collaborating with Destiny. I as far
as I know like almost at all anymore. Uh they might I don't know
how they talk in DMs. I'm saying almost at all cuz I don't know
for sure. I don't know what their DMs are. Right. But Josiah
is the person who gave him this idea that you can't lower yourself
to their level. you'll like or sorry, you can't hold yourself
to a higher standard. You have to use the same rhetoric. But
this isn't like about rhetoric. It's not about disavowing rhetoric.
It's about disavowing somebody putting a [__] bullet
through Charlie Kirk's neck, right? You could say, okay, rhetorically
we we shouldn't be that far off of them. Or rhetorically, like
we should procedurally we should do what they do. You could say,
yeah, we have to use the same tricks they do, the same like tactics
they do. But I don't think that goes to going, "Oh, this guy
just got he's got clear political assassination against my political
opposition. Oh, I'm not going to disavow it." I don't and I I
don't think unless unless it was Destiny at this point, I'm not
sure if any conservative would disavow that. But for basically
anybody, if that happened to like Hassan, I think a lot of conservatives
would come out and say this is crazy. This is insane. I actually
do. I think on the premise your major political opponent, right,
gets necked like that, you go, "Oh, this is [__]
nuts. We all need to lower the temperature. I think would Trump
do it? Probably not. I I don't think so. I think Trump would
have like different I don't know what Trump would do exactly,
but I have no faith that he would do the right thing. >> But
honestly, I feel like we saw these sorts of reactions coming
when a lot of them they freaked the [__] out because
Trump had like a a really photographic
moment after the assassination attempt on him and that pissed
them off more than it did the idea that he almost got assassinated.
They were like, "Great, this is like a epic photo. We lost the
election." Like, "Okay, that's pretty
>> Yeah. Yeah, I remember that. That people were saying
elections over and stuff. And a lot of people did not like that.
They felt like they listen, what are they going to do, Cherry?
What are they going to do? Are they going to like try to drive
voter turnout off of that shooting? They're Okay, so Destiny,
he's literally compelled to. He's He's like forced to make fun
of him. He's forced to say that it was a good thing. He's forced
to say Trump should have caught that bullet, right? If they're
going to try to get Trump elected off of that photo, then is
it is Destiny not like literally forced to mock it and to >> he's
he like he is helping it. But I'm just saying that like that
was his argument from before with uh Erica Kirk >> like
oh I have to do it. If they're going to drive off this I have
to I'm obligated to
>> that all the violence is coming on the left. Donald
Trump can go on TV. He can say proud boys stand back and stand
by. They can go on parlor and say we heard you. They can go to
the capital and break in and try to insurrect. They can get convicted
in front of a jury. And then Donald Trump can pardon them. And
we can come out and go, "Hey guys, uh, why aren't Democrats justifying
violence and pretend that the problem is coming from the left?
Democrats do a disservice to this." >> Wait, wasn't st
am I crazy or was standback in standby in 2016? Was it in 2020
or 2016? Maybe it was 2020. >> Charlottesville, right?
>> No. Well, maybe also, but I thought it I thought it
was 2016 where he was like, "Prowboy, stand back." I thought
it was around It wasn't 2020. Okay. 2017 2020. Okay. Yeah. I
wasn't I wasn't sure. I knew it was during one of the debates,
like a presidential debate. I just couldn't remember if it was
Biden or Hillary that was up there with him. Yeah. Yeah. I just
I remember the debate background. I just couldn't remember if
it was Biden or Hillary that was debating him >> cuz it
was like the same blue background. I got it. I got it.
of the United States. Let me say all of
Destiny. So the thing is, why did you say to your co-host
the bullet that the bullet that the bullet was for Trump? Why
did you say to your co-host that the best place for the bullet
was Trump? Why did you say that? >> Why did Donald Trump
call what aboutism? What aboutism? I'm asking you a question.
What about the >> I can't be what aboutism if it's my question,
Destiny? Why won't Donald Trump disappear
that Kirk >> Destiny? Allow Andrew Allow Andrew Allow Andrew
to repeat his question in and let him answer ask the question
then you answer it. Okay, Andrew. >> No, not I I want to
hear the other question Donald Trump. >> Let him ask the
question, Destiny, and then you answer it.
Uh, Rhox, I just think I personally think that a lot of these
people, if it was like a right-wing shooter in the same way that
came out and mer,
I do think, oh, we can watch this after. I do think that media
personalities would come out and say, "Yeah, this is don't don't
do this. This is [__] insane. We don't want violence.
We could beat their ideas." I think Tim P would do that. I think
a bunch of the performative would do that because again, it's
just like marketwise, it's the most effective messaging.
I understand that you think these these people are morally bankrupt.
I'm not counting on their morals to do it. It is just the more
intelligent messaging to do. That's the problem.
>> Destiny told his co-host when asked point blank if he
wanted the bullet to kill Trump uh that the worst thing that
could have happened was the bullet missing. He said this to Pisco,
"I watched it." Okay, this guy is an offiscation machine. And
you know what else, Destiny? Why should we believe you? I think
you are glad Kirk is dead. And uh all of your tweets seem to
prove that. And you would have been happy if Trump was assassinated.
You've made that very clear. So why not just be uh truthful for
once in your life and say the truth that you don't care that
Kirk is dead and you're actually probably glad he is. Isn't that
really what's true? I don't want anybody in this country to die
to political violence. I don't think in the United States of
America that should be happening. I don't know why it's so hard
for the president to say the same. I think it'd be the easiest
thing in the world as a president. Biden did it for 4 years.
Why everything was way cooler when he was here like in terms
of temperature. >> See, like this is the whole thing. If
you're if you're just going to come out and say it in the end,
right, why why are you well, yeah, I guess the contradictory
statements, but why if you're just going to come on the on the
principle of like, oh, I don't want to do this. You just let
Andrew Wilson walk you to like actually saying I disavow all
violence, I guess. So, what was the rest of it? It's just all
performance. It's all like, yeah, like actually, you just kind
of proved Andrew Wilson right on the like, I'm not going to believe
these people thing. You just said you had a principle that you
wouldn't say this. You wouldn't disavow. And now I don't unless
Donald did he get an emergency update, Donald Trump actually
just disavowed all violence on all sides. Did that happen?
Was there in the middle of this debate, Donald Trump came out
and disavowed violence on all sides?
>> Um maybe there's something about Anna yelling at him
that he doesn't mind as much as uh Andrew.
>> I don't Yeah, I don't. >> Easiest thing in the
world is a president. Biden did it for four years. It's why everything
was way cooler when he was here. Like in terms of temperature,
uh the Clintons have no problem saying it. Barack Obama has no
problem saying it. Kla Harris has come out and said it. Every
Democratic lawmaker and leader has basically come out and said
it. But for some reason on the Republican side, it's just civil
>> I wonder why he doesn't say Bush. Like Bush would say
this, too. Because Bush would you could easily say Bush respects
norms way more. And I think it makes a punchier point. >> Civil
War. Civil War. And the the Republican president of the United
States who has presided over more violence politically in this
country, more large protests than any president in all of US
history, for some reason can't bring himself to say all of us
need to calm down. And >> so Trump is love to say Trump
is This is all you care about? Are the political >> Answer
the question, bro. Did Trump deserve the bullet? >> Did
Donald Trump
on his side ever? Did Donald Trump, did Trump deserve the >> You
can't answer the question. We're We're here to play. >> No,
bro. It's my turn to ask the question. It's your turn to answer
the bullet. >> Did Trump dismount violence in this country
ever? >> Did he deserve the bullet? Yes, he's decided.
But again, I just did. Now your turn. Now your turn. It's your
turn. Donald Trump. I never said that. No, I never said that.
Okay. Except you did to your co-host. >> No, I did. Oh,
wait. When did Donald Trump Wait, wait. When did Donald Trump
co-host, you lying sack of if he wanted Donald Trump
violence
and this is Yeah. Yep. And this is when when you're putting YouTubers
when you're putting YouTubers and tweeters on the same level
as the president the United States. >> Wait, why are you
why are you examining me? Wait, hold on. I'm not the president.
I could say crazy. I didn't say that. You're just No, I didn't
say that. Wait, why are you wait Why would you read my words?
Why are you focusing on YouTubers right now? >> Why do
I have to act more civil than the president does? This is unfair.
>> Dude,
there's no way. There's no way. How is that possible?
How do you Dude, I feel like like fake a disconnect disconnection
or something. Like it's actually pathetic to show up and just
get obliterated like this. I don't know to just go to go from
I didn't say that to Andrew reads the quote and he's like why
would you focus on why would you focus on YouTubers right now?
>> It's this is why conservatives are absolutely brain
broken when it when it comes to violence in this country. That's
why it'll continue
going to turn around and be like I can't believe it.
>> Jack B Jack Bic sitting over here. But why male models?
But why but why male models? What is happening to this guy? >> Some
[__] Zoolander [__] over here. He's just
he's blue steel into the camera the whole time. Well, I do agree
you want this to continue.
>> Are absolutely brain broken when it comes to violence
in this country. That's why it'll continue
to turn around and be like this guy's got nothing. Dude, I'm
sorry. I'm like actually getting such a kick out of this guy
being over here. He's got nothing useful to contribute at all.
Uh, this guy is like the Piers. >> There's nothing useful
happening.
>> Well, that's true. I was going to say he's like the
Piers Morgan equivalent of the whatever girl in the German fascist
>> right? That's who he is right now. He's just like sitting
here. He's like going to start doing like weird faces at the
>> I can't believe it. What's happening >> Okay,
Destiny, if you care so much about political violence in America,
why don't you lead the way yourself without mentioning anybody
else?
Why don't Why don't you, Destiny, right now just outright condemn
the murder of Charlie Kirk? >> One because we've been doing
that for a decade. One side can't
>> We've been doing this for a decade. >> You've
been doing that for a decade,
>> brother. You just You just refused to disavow. You He
like was just refusing to disavow when Trump got shot at. You
haven't been doing it for like months, let alone a decade. What
are we talking about here? You were just doing this in the last
major shooting of like a rep of a conservative figure. You literally
were doing the same thing. What are we talking about? This is
like who's who's been doing this for a Who's we? I It's >> right?
Condemn the murder of Charlie
>> One because we've been doing that for a decade. One
side can't turn down the temperature. The other side can't turn
down the temperature. If Donald
>> I don't know what would be >> I'm sorry that's
so he just asked to condemn the murder of Charlie Kirk that happened
5 days ago. What does he mean? We've been doing this for 10 years.
>> I don't >> Am I missing something? >> I
I I think he's just not listening and he's like continue to just
do his rhetoric like the lines he wrote down. Right. But um uh
the thing that's Oh god. There's like a funny thing going on
>> Oh [__] But I lost Hold on. I just need
to go back >> one because we've been doing that for a decade.
One >> see into the future. You are right. Yes. Could you
condemn the murder of Charlie Kirk? We've been doing that for
a >> One side can't
turn down the >> Oh, we got a raid coming in. Uh, it's
a Dickers. Dickers with the 15 viewers coming in. Thank you very
much, Dickers, for the raid. Checking out this Piers Morgan panel.
Anakasparian, Andrew Wilson, Destiny, and Jack.
But why male models? Pobic. Okay. Jack Pobic very bewildered
by anything Destiny is >> Decade. One side cannot.
>> Bellpal says uh he's talking about Democrats denouncing
inflammatory rhetoric for over a decade.
>> that is what he's saying. >> You think okay. >> Yeah,
that is what he's saying. Sorry, I didn't see the the Hassan
laugh, but that is what he's saying. I I understand what he's
saying. And by the way, I think you can absolutely Here's the
thing. I want I want people to understand that you have to be
subhuman. You have to be ADIQ to think that Destiny's proving
that they won't answer a question about Trump denouncing violence.
Okay? The thing that they will do infinitely is sit here and
farm Destiny refusing to disavow Charlie Kirk getting shot. >> That
is the economic thing to do. That's the optical thing to do.
It's a political win. It is the win in every possible dimension
for them. So if you think that they'll ever shift out of just
winning infinitely, farming Destiny for infinite points, you
are
right. You're you're just totally. So he's not proving that.
That's the best outcome you could hope for is Destiny proves
that they want to answer the question about Trump. But that's
not what's happening here. Right? That's not what's happening
at all. So if he wanted to do that, what he could do is he could
do Yeah, we already said this free specific welcome. Welcome.
You're you're here from yesterday. So, if you wanted to do that,
you do the the condemnation sandwich. Okay. Yeah, of course I
condemn the shooting of Charlie Kirk. I just find it a little
weird how you guys will not condemn Donald Trump refusing to
call it violence on both sides, even though there has been violence
in both sides. We just lost actual state lawmakers in Minnesota
because of Republican violence. We just we've lost people from
violence, right? But none of that is to say, even even if you
say that, I just want some some acknowledgement that the president
of the United States won't turn the temperature down from some
of you guys, but I obviously disavow Charlie Kirk getting shot.
You just you sandwich it on both sides. It's so easy, right?
And then you don't have to get farmed infinitely for being a
complete [__] What do you think the effect will be
on Desty's career from this? This has got to be the worst look
he's ever Well, we aren't all the way through it yet, Dicker.
So, hold on. Don't spoil cuz we're not even close to all the
way through it yet. All right, we've got a lot more to go, including
I haven't even seen the most clippable moment from this yet.
So,
uh I don't know if he keeps getting embarrassed like this in
front of people and having Spurgeouts in his own chat. And we'll
see. I don't think it matters to me. It doesn't matter. So to
me, I don't think it probably matters to his audience if he loses
these, right? Cuz I they don't have somebody who's going to make
who's going to give them liberal talking points who also does
rip analogies yet. They need the the perfect ripe analogizer.
Then he doesn't exist. And that's really like top of the priority
list. All right. You don't even have to be good at the politics.
It's just like the analogies have to hit.
>> Do you ever see him stopping politics? Does he ever
get tired of this or is he pigeonhold to being a political commentator
forever?
>> Uh I could see him stopping politics. Yeah. Uh, we will
check it out after this. Easy, shoot me that in DMs and we'll
check it out after this. All right. Yeah. Oh, man. This has been
this has been a rough look so far. I don't think he needs to
like doesn't need to keep doing politics. Rhox, I don't think
he has to do anything. I mean, he's probably got enough money
to retire, but I think he um >> it just doesn't seem like
he really believes any of his political ideology. They do
they do seem spite driven. So, at some point, I don't know, you
would just think if you don't really care about this stuff and
you're not you're not getting the the dopamine hit from spiting
your enemies, don't you just drop it and look for somewhere where
you do get that hit? >> Yeah, you might. Um,
sorry. Yeah, I I think you could go for the dopamine hits. I
think the bigger thing to me, like that is a big thing and I
think he does need that. I think he almost get that all the time.
I think even being like totally reviled by people, I think he
still gets that same >> just being able to go live. He
still gets that. >> Yeah, I think I think and people will
still farm him and stuff and it'll I think he still gets it.
>> I think so. But I think there's another factor there
outside of the dopamine hit and that's like the ego. I think
he wanted to be I think he was ready to move and try to be like
somebody respected in politics and that can never come back now.
Like he could probably keep doing politics even like this would
pro he'd be able to do like some panels and stuff again but he'll
never be somebody who's like respected, right? and that's what
he was trying to do. >> I think that's gone forever and
that's like probably the the rough part for >> I think
of um like I I've seen Fuentes and he almost hates his audience.
Like the people who would give him a dopamine hit, the people
who do give him money, he despises those people. They're like
gross. You guys are like
um social freaks. You make me look bad. I feel like he's going
down that path of having
having an audience that humiliates him and maybe it >> he
is going down that path but you so I think I think that is probably
going to hit him pretty hard too but I think he is he's got like
the system set up where he can stop that right I think >> if
you wanted to. Yeah.
>> Hold on. I got uh I got linked to clip and the comment
was we've been disavowing on the left for over a decade. You
you genuinely do hate conservatives, don't you? >> Very
much so. Like I'm like I've moved full on to like the political
violence level or the real violence level when it comes to conservative
people. Yeah. I think they need to be like exiled.
>> Oh,
when was this >> from my country? I think they are demonstrabably
evil people by any moral system that most people would use. And
then I just hate them because they tend to destroy the outcomes
related to this country, which is what I'm concerned with. Yeah.
Absolutely.
Wow. Wow. Like eight years ago. Oh, cool.
That's ancient. Well, well,
>> are a lot of the clips that they pull up of Hassan.
>> Yeah,
this is what What do you guys think? Just on a on like a sort
of irony level, do you think Dan feels anything knowing that
like
>> you got [__] Okay, bro, you're getting too
big for your boots. >> Okay, thank you very much for the
donation.
Okay. Uh on a on an irony level, do you think Dan's going to
feel any like pain knowing that the movement he's building is
absolutely going to get his friend cancelled way before Hassan?
That like if if they start hardcore deplatforming people, it's
going to be way worse for Destiny than it does for than it gets
for Hassan. Like Destiny set himself to have way worse issues.
Yeah. Nobody thinks so. Nobody thinks he's going to care. >> Actually,
I don't think about Dan. So you lost me at Do you think Dan?
What? No. No, I don't. That is, you know what? That's fair. That's
fair.
>> Right. Condemn the murder of Charlie
>> One, because we've been doing that for a decade. One
side can't reduce the temperature. The other side can't turn
down the temperature. If Donald Trump
>> then the left shouldn't until he does. Republicans
need accountability for their actions. They need some responsibility
for >> the accountability being a bullet through this neck.
Okay, that's the accountability.
That's the accountability he wants. Hey, we can't get accountability
through like anybody disavowing. I just want the the accountability
is going to be people getting necked like this.
>> Even though you've taken on yourself, >> let me
bring in Jack Pobic. >> Absolutely. Democrat. That's enough.
I'll bring in Jack Pobic. Jack, >> I don't think he wants
both sides of
>> What is your response to this? >> I I mean, peers,
this this is exactly what I'm talking about. you know, this this
type of ideology where you've got someone who's willing to mock
Erica, who's who's been standing strong for her family, for her
children, who's just she will never be able to grow old with
Charlie. She will never be able to be with them again, have more
children, to have grandchildren. >> This is like Jack's
purpose on the panel is just to be like, I'm very I'm very torn
up that Charlie's gone, right? That's his purpose here. I do
find this. >> He's doing perfect. >> Well, I don't
know how close they were, but I find it kind of gross when people
do this who aren't that close. So, I don't know. I don't know
how close they are. It gets it gets pretty rough for me. I don't
like I don't like the people I've seen some people I know aren't
close to Charlie like farm that and it's pretty disgusting >> to
have those memories to raise them. >> It's all gone. Mhm.
>> Every single moment of that future that they had was
gone because someone fired a bullet at Charlie Kirk that said,
"Hey, fascist catch." >> And and now you have people celebrating
it. And when you ask people about >> the bullet that was
fired, how are you lying about this? >> Shut up, Destiny.
Shut up. >> I think it was also I think that was the one
that was fired. Why? >> I don't. >> Dude, look at
his smile. He loves this. That's the type of sick he is. He enjoys
getting a rise out of people. >> Yeah. Yeah.
It's uh
that is that is what he wants. Yeah. That is what he wants. >> He
should feel some sort of embarrassment for smiling like wait
until after the panel to smile and bask in it. >> You should
have a little more shame than doing it openly. But yeah, I think
uh he's just got like this Yeah. this attention-seeking like
need that he that he fuels through politics. But this is why
what I I I always told people when I was first covering uh like
kind of realized what kind of person he was, right? First started
covering like some of his political takes. It's dude, he is the
worst person to have in charge of or in front of your movement.
You have this guy involved in your movement. He doesn't care
about the political movement at all. He is there to arrandise
himself, to enrich himself, to get attention for himself, but
he does not care about the politics at all. Not even a little
bit. Right?
Not even a tiny amount. Uh, and he he like he's going to always
put himself ahead of whatever movement he's representing. That's
it. That's it. >> The one that was fired was the notices
>> and and now you have people celebrating. >> Now
I know why he remembers. >> And when you ask people
>> uh Oh, hold on. Never mind. >> It's not even the
bullet that was fired. How are you lying about this? >> Shut
up, Destiny. Shut up. Holy [__] You're such You're
so dude. Oh my god. You're not even sight the right bullet. You're
such a disgusting piece of [__] Holy [__]
>> That actually wasn't the right bullet.
>> That wasn't actually the right bullet. You don't even
know. Do you even care about Charlie? Um, you didn't say the
right bullet. Actually, you didn't care. You only said one of
the four bullets, but not the one that he fired. And that makes
you a disgusting.
Actually, >> you disgusting piece of >> like he's
not even It's funny cuz he's like not even looking at reaction.
He's like he's just enjoying in his head how it looks. Destiny.
You're so shameless, dude. Oh my god. You're not even inside
the right bullet. You're such a disgusting piece of [__]
>> No, I didn't see Andrew.
>> We have to zoom in on everyone's >> everyone's
reaction. Okay,
>> Destiny. [__] You're such You're so shameless,
dude. Oh my god. You're not even the right bullet. You're such
a disgusting piece of [__] >> Did Anna have
any
reaction? Destiny
[__] You're so You're so shameless, dude. Oh my god.
Jesus Christ. Anna Kasparian is locked the [__] in.
>> She's locked in right now. I I think this is like actually
if you just are used to this Desty guy, this is just like how
you would act. It's like I don't even want to give him the satisfaction
of having a reaction to his
>> Well, we remembered her last week. >> She said
that she didn't want to talk to him. She doesn't take him seriously
because he puts on a butt plug when he walks around in public
or something like that. I forget what she said, >> but
she's disgusted with him before this even starts. >> I
Yeah, I love that she just sees the uh Yeah, she sees the rage
baiting. She's seen it for a while now. What was his correction
there? I don't even know what his correction is. He's uh she's
everybody. She's everybody who actually cares about like their
political movement and having any success in America. Okay, just
done with the rage baiting. Done with the rage baiting. Go away.
You're not useful. You're not >> The right bullet. You're
such a disgusting piece of Holy. What a pedantic. What a pedantic.
>> What a pedantic. This guy's a [__] >> Oh,
wait. She did actually.
What a pedantic. This guy's a [__]
>> I would like to let I would like to let Jack finish
his point, please.
>> And and they'll claim there's no And >> Jack Pobec
Kirk celebrations. There is a social cancer. Jack Pobec on emotional
impact on his family.
Sorry. It's like he just came on to talk. They brought him on
for that. But it's like it's weird to me that he's just like
I'm really up right now. To go on a panel to do that. It just
seems >> they'll claim there's no leftist connection. They'll
claim there's no there and and then go so far as to lie and say
there's some kind of Christian conservative connection when you
you could see the writing on the bullet casings. And so you know
these are very common symbols associate whatever the point is
right it should be very very clear are we connected with our
humanity or are we not and some people are willing to do that
Anna's been willing to do that we've we've done shows together
they've been they've been fine they've been good we've >> Destiny
was willing to do that when he was trying to Lauren Southern
then he he found his humanity then okay can Lauren Southern date
this guy so he could have a soul A so he stops hurting the democratic
movement. That's like the requirement. Where's Lauren Southern?
Please, Lauren, please. >> Gousted. We've done the back
and forth that Dustin and I and I in the past have had shows
together where I, you know, before he kind of took this turn
and you know, you you think there are people who can just be
willing to stand up for humanity. You know, Jack, it it reminds
me a bit of the journey I've gone on, very different circumstances,
but the
war, the reason I asked everybody on the pro Palestinian side
for months after the war started, do you condemn what I did is
I think it was very enlightening as to the humanity of the person
by how they responded. If there >> Oh, Piers Piers watching
the program. Piers is watching the program.
Of course, I do. the mass murder of civilians on October the
7th was a horrendous atrocity then we can move on to an intellectually
honest debate. If they refuse to condemn what did it's a completely
different debate and similarly right now I feel if you can't
condemn a lot of what the IDF are doing frankly it's my opinion
uh in Gaza then the same thing if you if you're unequivocally
like it it's all fine with 20,000 plus kids being then I've got
a problem with that too but I do think you've got to try and
maintain in all of these debates a modicum of humanity
about people who are actually being killed. And what is terrifying
about the mindset of a lot of people on the woke left I've seen
since Charlie Kirk's death is the brazen glee that they're taking
to his murder. And then when I see even Destiny who's a very
wellfollowed person on the internet wellknown when Destiny frankly
if you can't bring yourself just to say the murder was horrific
and should never have happened it's a very simple sentence it's
just basic humanity it is Deste okay is he is he like totally
losing it again >> very
well followed person on the internet well known when Destiny
Frankly, if you can't bring yourself just to say
>> the murder was horrific,
it's a very simple sentence. It's just basic humanity. It really
makes me despair for where everything is going because it's indicative
of the mindset of I can't give an inch to my political opponents,
therefore I lose my humanity. How can that be right? >> They're
saying he's typing
>> because he's looking to respond as soon as opponents
that won't recognize or acknowledge anything they've done is
wrong. It's it's all it's done has gotten us here. This is where
we're at because of that exact mindset. Will any of the conservatives
here acknowledge the conservative that murdered Melissa Hortman
and her husband and shot the other senator in Minnesota? >> Yeah,
of course. Yeah. >> Conservative that No, no, no. That
it was a conservative shooter. >> I don't know the details
on that particular case. If I did and it turned out that it was
the and it turned out it was the case, of course, I would say
that such violence should be disavowed. thing is you can't hold
your entire
>> like it it's just walking like how do you not know that
you just look doing this like you you go and you say something
that they could easily say yeah yeah of course we disavow that
you just get punched in the face you look like a complete [__]
to everyone why would you it's like will you will you acknowledge
that 2 plus 2 is four yeah 2 plus two is four oh I guess I'm
just totally now like oh great job best debated on the internet
>> how horrible would it look If Andrew is like, "Yeah,
I can I um I disavow that." And he's like, "Okay." And if it
was a conservative shooter, like, "Yes, that would make Andrew
like the biggest hypocrite if he's like, "I condemn it." Oh,
but if it was a conservative shoot, actually, maybe they had
a really good point. Like, what the [__] happens
after
>> You're not supposed to ask a question that you don't
understand what the answer will be or why the answer would be
like groundbreaking
>> or why. Yeah. Why it helps your argument, but it's just
he's like floundering completely. It's very
>> yeah very weird behavior based on what you think Trump
is doing or not doing. What does it have to do with you destiny?
It has nothing to do with you. You could easily
lead by example and say let's all tone down the violence
president of the United States. That's what Democrats have been
doing. >> Wait, you can't lead by example because you're
not the president. >> That's one side. If one side wants
to fight and the other side doesn't, then you're going to fight.
One side can't decide not to fight. That makes no sense. What
does that happen? >> What do you mean it makes no sense?
Some guy comes up to you to fight. You can easily say I don't
want to. You don't really have the choice there. >> Lead
by example then. Lead by example. >> You can't lead by
example. That's called
>> Right now, let me let me jump in. You actually have
>> Okay, I got to do this before we go, guys. We uh >> we
are what? Nine. No. Uh 10 subs away. No, no, no. Less subs. like
probably five subs. I'm trying to think of what we got for for
kicks here. We got five 10. We got at least 20 bucks in kicks.
So, we'll say we are six subs away from another two hours on
the stream, guys. I need those subs. We need to monetize. We
need to add more time to the stream. We got 49 minutes left.
We still got all of the Candace Owens content. We got the Tim
Pull reaction to Desty's clips. And I shut off the desk fund
cuz you guys weren't donating to it. It's just better to do time
on the stream, okay? It's just better to do it that way. All
right. So guys, sub through kick, donate through either of the
uh TTS methods, okay? There's kickbot, there is there's Streamlabs,
all right? Throw throw kicks in if you want, I guess, even though
they don't pop up on stream. Sub sub, donate, donate, donate.
Add more time to the stream. Really appreciate it, guys. And
last but not least, if you want to help monetize, but you aren't
super concerned about how much time gets added to the stream,
okay? You can go over to patreon.com/jok.
Sign up for the Patreon. All right? Couple different perks over
there. It's good time.
All right. Okay. All right. I just need to get that out before
we get to like the crescendo of this and before we get to all
the other stuff.
I don't want to. You don't really have the choice there.
>> Uh there's Soapbox Society with the six or sorry, the
five gifted and marad dude. Thank you for the one gifted. Guys,
you've added two more hours to the stream. I just wanted to do
that before we uh had to get through that without >> Nice
DMs. Get DMs.
>> Important. Critical.
>> Critical. Okay, we reset this. We are ready to go. More
time on the stream. Sorry. I want to be focused for the next
part of the stream. And I uh I don't want to be distracted, guys.
So, I need to add add the time now. All right. Need to add the
time now. Here we go. 2 hours 47 45.
Boom. Massive. Huge. Absolutely huge.
Okay. Let's continue. >> Careful. That's called dying.
See, I thought I thought I actually
thought, let me let me jump in.
Let me jump in here. I actually I actually felt that Anna hit
the nail on the head here, which is she did not need to wait
for Donald Trump to comment on this to make her own mind up about
what had happened. That is intellectual honesty,
right? Yes, it may have been somebody that she totally disagree
with on many issues. >> The simple humane thing to do.
Oh, Desessie just did the same thing that uh that Andrew did.
Amazing. We're just going to assume she doesn't she doesn't like
me. So, she's the other she's the other ideology now. I just
get to tell you where you are. Okay. All right. Cool. Cool. Cool.
Cool. >> With any event like this is to ask yourself, how
do I personally feel
>> Hold on. Hold on, guys. There's a moment coming up here,
but uh Anna took that personally like this is to ask. She took
that personally.
head. Why? >> The simplest humane thing to do with any
event like this is I'm >> not going to let that one go.
You think you just You think you just talk [__] like
that?
You You've
done You think you just talk [__] like
>> Yo, that eye goes hard cuz her eyeliner is sharp. >> It's
pretty good. It's pretty good to ask yourself, how do I personally
feel about it? Not what does Donald Trump think about it or what
does Joe Biden think about it or what does Timbuktu think about
it. It's what do I personally feel about this? It didn't take
me very long, Destiny, to understand that I felt repulsed by
the execution of somebody in cold blood with his wife and two
young children there watching. It's a human reaction. I don't
need to know what Donald Trump thinks about it there >> at
all. I don't understand why you need to wait for him before your
own >> I need to wait for anybody. No, you're not asking
how we feel about it. You're asking what the public statements
should be. And the public statements should be the president
of the United States. Yes, you are.
>> Uh, okay. The butts sniff a guy comes in with a opinion.
I've blocked you from the the stream chat now. I can't explain
it again. >> I need for a public statement. >> I'm
asking where is your humanity? You can't just say the murder
was >> your humanity, peers. You guys are playing into
this. Exactly. I think you probably know it. I think Cornell
was right about this. You know where your bread is buttered as
well. You guys play into this. It's insane to me that the president
of the United States can't say, "Hey, all of us need to be less
violent. We all need to calm the down." That the president of
the United States can't say, >> "Oh, did I miss did I miss
an awesome moment there for a public statement?" >> I'm
asking where is your humanity. You can't just say the murder
was your humanity. Piers, you guys are playing into this. Exactly.
I think you probably
>> I think Cornell was right about this. You know where
your bread is buttered as well. You guys play into this. This
is insane to me that the president of the United States can't
say, "Hey, all of us need to be less violent. We all need to
calm the down." That the president of the United States can't
say this, but you will endlessly scour Twitter and YouTube for
leftists to bring on and say, "Don't you guys disavow the violence."
It's absolutely absurd to me. >> You know, Colonel West
should have stayed in his seat. We were debating free speech.
Actually,
>> you are the leftist that he brought on for the circus
and you've played your role perfectly. How does he say this?
>> He doesn't know. He doesn't he doesn't know. Okay. He
thinks Piers is inviting him on because he's a really intelligent
interlocutor. He thinks Piers respects his intelligence and the
opinions he brings. He thinks that's why Piers has him here right
now. Like Piers didn't just bring him here to be humiliated repeatedly
over and over and over again. >> I think it was Adam friended
from the Sitchin Adam show that was like uh you are Piers Morgan's
LOL.
Congratulations.
That's where you go now. >> It is. It is. But Adam was
totally right. Adam's 100% correct. Like there's no there's no
way to go back against that. And whether the debating whether
well let me finish let me finish and whether the overuse whether
the overuse of words like fascist was actually empowering derange
young minds to think they were battling actual new
fascists. And actually when Andrew pointed out to Cornell that
he had used the phrase neofascist about Trump that's when Cornell
decided he couldn't take part in the debate anymore when he was
reminded of something he had said. He didn't try and deny it.
He just said, "I don't want to have this debate." And left. >> Pierce,
how long have you been in the United States like following our
>> Hold on a second. Oh no.
Adben Peers Mega Peers. Mega Pies.
>> In that order. Were people going around the spelling?
>> Hold on. There's more. I People must have been going
around this. There's more. I I got to send a better a bigger
one. I thought they'd give me at least one person. Anakasparian
Jack Pobic Andrew Wilson of Piers.
He called it cancer at some point. He called it cancer. I'm missing
that time stamp here. But uh what adban >> the tweet >> this
adban peers mega nuke piers mega nuke puries
linker permaban sorcerer IP ban sorcerer IP ban sakula 7day skitso
mega nuke 3day voice. So apparently his squeaky voice came through
as well. >> Got hit. >> Unlucky. Yeah, cool did get
hit. Unlucky. Unlucky.
>> Uh, but the cancer you're thinking of is that was in
his tweet. >> Oh, was it? Okay. Amazing. Just amazing stuff,
guys.
You love to see it. I got to link the food shops URL as well.
This is uh amazing stuff, guys. Amazing
>> It hurts. What hurts? >> I don't know. Watching
watching the guy who's like who you're getting all of your money
from slowly fade. I would imagine probably painful. It hurts.
It hurts. It hurts. Okay. Uh, hold on. I can't remember if there's
there might be one more thing with the logs, but I'm going to
continue on with this. Give me a second. How long have you been
in the United States like following our
>> over 20 years I've lived and worked in
>> Okay. If you've lived and worked in America, I grew
up as a conservative listening to Rush Limbbo and to Glenn Beck
and to Billy Cunningham and to Sean Hannity. You're going to
sit here and pretend like Democrats are the ones that started
the name calling. I heard them call Obama and the Clinton
communist. When did I say that? I heard them call. I'm just saying.
Why are we pretending that some
>> Why would Cornell West walk out on a debate when we're
literally talking about the importance of speech? Makes no sense
to me. >> If if speech is important, then the president
should exercise it more cautiously.
Republicans and Republicans have been You can't stop. >> You
got millions of followers and you think it's fine to show them
you're mocking a widow. You cannot choose for your opponent not
to fight you. If Republicans
down the rhetoric, then f who cares? Donald Trump's going to
use the rhetoric that led her to being >> 2 days before
she died
with us. This is all it's just virtue signaling. You guys, you
guys are excited about it. You guys love it. >> How is
it
possibly? It's exciting to you. It's insane to me. Yeah. >> How
is it that you said this guy can't be a leftist because he grew
up in a white Christian household when you grew up in a white
Christian household by your own admission just now and you're
leftist Destiny
6 years old. This guy was 22 and he lived at home to do anything.
What does that what does it have to do with >> 20 years
to separate myself from my parents ideology. I didn't live with
them still. Jesus. >> So he separate really like Wait,
hold on. How long was he living outside of the home for in the
clip that we watched? That was like what? Four years, 5 years
outside of his house or something tops, right? We watched that
clip. That's from 8 years ago or >> So, six is it 6 months,
1 year, 20 years. Why does it matter the how long it took to
separate? You just got >> Oh, since 15. Okay. >> This
thing is impossible. And you yourself are a leftist who grew
up in a Christian conservative household. Dude, >> you're
the worst hypocrite.
You think you think you think that a 22year-old has as much time
to separate himself from the ideology that he grew up with 36y
old saying? You just made the comparison. Of course you did.
It's
Look at you. Let me jump in. Let me jump in. Let me jump in.
Let me >> One second, guys. Okay, I'm back. Picking what
to order for food. All >> Look at you. Let me jump in.
Let me jump in. Let me jump in. Let me ask Jack. Jack, you you
know the Kirk family well. You've been around the Kirk family,
I think, since this is appalling murder has happened. When you
hear Destiny saying, "Who cares about the fact that he openly
publicly mocked Erica Kirk, a grieving widow within literally
a day?" Also, as an aside, okay, while Piers does the uh Jack,
tell me about how sad you are again. I can't see your eyes. Uh
while he does that, I'm just going to put as an aside. I'll reset
the blocks in the stream chat at some point, but I actually don't
know how to do it right now. So, if you're knocked out of there,
I'll figure it out tomorrow. Okay? But it's it's actually very
helpful for me because I only really look at the stream chat
in my side window and anybody who's like who's likely to say
something that I feel like I should correct, you know? I just
uh I just block them out and it works so well. Stream goes so
much more smoothly. Day or two of her husband being murdered.
How does that make you feel as a friend of the family? >> That's
it's very angry
peers, you know. And and here's the thing. Can we also acknowledge
the sewing out is soying out is so stupid at all five of these
people would talk to Alex Jones and he laughed at kindergarteners
dying. Do you do you really believe that that's an accurate description
of what Alex Jones did? Rhox he laughed at kindergarteners dying.
I feel like that's like a that's like a distortion of a distortion.
Like he he had a distorted view on that that event,
right? Yeah. But hold on. You guys understand that if you're
deluded and you think that that these people didn't die, that
it was like actors or something, you actually believe that. Unless
you think he just didn't believe it, right? But it' be a weird
thing to pretend to believe. That's all. Like I just don't I
don't Unless I missed it. Maybe I just don't see it, right? Like
I I think there's a difference between not believing it happened
and which, by the way, you could still say in effect he did that,
but I think like realistically he's paid for that as well a little
bit, you know? Yeah. Like I I think
it it feels different. It feels different. You You think Alex
Jones genuinely believes a fraction of what he says? Probably.
I think he's like a He's one of those people that if he didn't
believe it at all, it doesn't make any sense that he wouldn't
have just gone the main like the mainstream news route. I think
that would have been far more profitable for him. Didn't he have
to pay $1.4 million because they proved he did actually believe
it? I actually think he has to pay $1.4 billion because he refused
to cooperate with the court case in any way. I thought anyway.
Um yeah, Rhox, I just think there's a different point here about
humanity that we're missing. um about like it's very different
when if Alex Jones was sitting there announcing, yeah, no, I
know that this is fake and I don't care that those kids die.
That's like the equivalent like Destiny has his eyes wide open
on this, right? He knows the facts of the situation and he's
still saying these same things. It's like very very different,
right? Should it be that different? Should it be like I don't
know that that's like a different argument, but it's just it's
like very different. I don't think that these people broadly
like care about, you know, all life is s is sacred and it all
needs to be protected. I don't think anybody in this panel really
cares about that obviously, right?
But there is something to be said when it's like this big a news
story like having the right message. It's political violence.
It's like a little different, right? I think there's like a lot
of things going on here at the same time.
>> Thing is is she's seeing all of it. She's going to see
all of it. Her her kids are going to watch this video one day.
It's just that's sort of the nature of of reality now. um they
will see all of this and they will see the reaction
and I just hope that that those of us
>> I mean if we're going to be concerned about kids reaction
to their parents online presence I don't think Charlie Kirk's
kids are the kids we should start with first. Okay.
>> Why is why is Destiny laughing? Destiny's laughing because
he has to meet the same argument all the time about his online
conduct and how his own son handles that. So he's laughing because
he can't engage with that honestly. Right. He he can't engage
with like that being a problem or else he has to engage with
like how terrible a father he is and that would be bad for >> Charlie
worked with Charlie who knew Charlie beyond the you know Tik
Toks and short videos can can also be there for those kids as
they grow up to let them know who who their dad was >> and
kids are going to grow up and watch old episodes of Piers Morgan
uncensored. How performative is this? Is everybody here? Did
we all get like a script before the show? What? They watch a
lot of old episodes of the JFar make the left look so bad and
you don't even
>> Anna's just been on point the whole time. Everything
Anna has said this entire time is so true, right? >> Realize
it. You are seriously so
>> Okay. Yeah, you can talk to your best friend. You really
are. I mean, have another 30-minut conversation about >> Maybe
I will. Maybe I will talk to Glen Beck about it. Oh, is that
is that is that naughty? >> How many conversations have
you had with you guys with anyone? So mean. Oh no, not I just
want to point out conversations with Nick were while he was having
a relationship with somebody who was basically a white supremacist
themselves. Okay, that's why those conversations happened.
Like that is actually why it's not that he had a it's not that
he, you know, principally changed in any way. He just couldn't
he couldn't defend hanging out with conservatives as much as
he wanted to with Lauren Southern and not talk to Nick. So that's
why he did it. It's not anything to do with principal. It's just
whatever is convenient for him at the >> The meanies on
Twitter
>> from women that you allegedly secretly recorded during
intimate moments. Destiny, I can't believe >> what what?
No way. Did she Did Queen Did Queen Anna Kasparian
really just bring that up?
Oh.
Oh sh How did she say that exactly? How many more lawsuits are
you going to face from women you allegedly secretly recorded?
Destiny,
>> not the meanies on Twitter.
from women that you allegedly secretly recorded during intimate
moments. Destiny, I can't believe anyone serious. >> Are
you really pull out? >> Can't believe anyone would take
you seriously. You're disgusting. And then wait, are you really
going to pull out Tw is he going to call this Twitter >> During
intimate moments, Destiny, I can't believe anyone serious. >> Are
you pull out
and you should be >> You want to pull out Twitter rumors
right now? Twitter. Uh >> Twitter rumors. apparently Twitter
rumors. Seems like uh were those Willy Mack logs? Were those
Twitter rumors? Are any of the things you've just discussed?
Any of the reasons like you're being uh legally pursued at all?
Are those all rumors?
Are they like,
you know what? You know, maybe he's just wishfully thinking,
okay, maybe he's just hoping in his heart of hearts that the
bills from Mr. Breler, from Andrew Breler are just rumors, okay?
That he's not going to have to pay those out. that he isn't actually,
you know, down 600k from it. He's just praying. Maybe that was
just a rumor. If I just say it was a Twitter rumor, maybe maybe
I could get away with it. Okay, maybe I don't have to pay it.
Oh boy. >> I can't believe anyone. Are you really? You
want to pull out embarrassing and you should be shunned from
public life with your disgusting treatment of all sorts of people,
including young leftwing girls, women
in the window. You're turning more blonde in the window.
Why is Anna snarking? Anna Kasparian.
Kasnarkian.
Snarkparion. I'm not sure. We'll have to figure out the name
later. Okay. I We love Listen, snarking's awesome. Okay. Snarking's
great for >> public life when you're disgusting.
>> And Snark Perion. Okay.
All sorts of people including young leftwing girls, >> You're
turning your blood now in the window. You're so you're like two
shades away from being host.
>> He's trying to say she's a Fox News host. No. Lots of
leftist people called out. In fact, I'd say more leftist people
probably called him out for this. Andrew Wilson counterpoints.
They're like, "Oh, no. Destiny would do this. Destiny is like
a total degenerate." No, you your consent would would get violated.
You should just know that if you hang out with Destiny, like
your consent will >> get for being a liberal. >> That's
that's literally what they said. The conservatives were on his
side. The leftists were the people who walked away. She sounds
like she could be
>> It was there was a a large amount of like conservatives
who weren't on his side, but they're the ones you would always
suspect to not be on his side, >> right? Nobody changed
their mind about him that was a conservative, I don't >> Oh,
that's crazy that this guy >> He's about to call her Yeah.
Nobody changed her mind. And he's about to call her a Fox News
host. I to me she sounds like a progressive news channel host.
Like, dare I say, a TYT host. She sounds like somebody who could
be like an anchor on the Young Turks or something.
Seems more in line with the opinions she's spewing on here. Spewing,
saying,
>> Does that make her his type? Like I don't understand.
>> I don't I don't know what he's going for >> Is
that Lauren Southern?
>> I I just want to know where did where did Destiny's
like talking ability go? That must have been from other people,
too, right? Cuz I swear to God, he used to be able to talk. And
at this point,
at this point, he's sounding like like this is, no offense to
Destiny, this is like some pisco level talk. Your hair's getting
more blind. You're on your way to being a Fox News host right
now. Actually, amazing stuff.
>> Please check DMs. I miss Jack Pacific. Be like, "Lord
have mercy." And Desty spurred out. Hold on. We got a clip. We
have a little clip here. >> Also, do you can you hurry
up? Do you want something different? No, that's >> Why
don't you, Destiny, right now just outright condemn the murder
of Charlie
>> One, because we've been doing that for a decade. One
side can't turn down the temperature. The other side can't turn
down the temperature. If Donald Trump can't, then the left shouldn't
until >> Jesus.
Kind of a little bit demonic. Yeah, a little bit demonic. I get
it. I get it. I get it. We get it. Okay,
I understand. All right, let's pull back into this this ancluding
young leftwing girls, women. You're turning more black now in
the window. You're so shades away from being an you embarrass
the left people away from the left. Make sure you understand
that you're embarrassing.
>> my response to being accused of, you know, of crimes.
Uh, I'm going to be as I possibly can. You need more lip filler,
sweetheart. Okay? You need you need more lip filler and a few
more shades of blonde if you want to be a Fox News host. Okay?
That's his response. That's apparently going to make uh it's
going to make the woman come back. So >> there's no morality
with you.
>> You're a woman abuser. You should get lip filler. Uh-huh.
>> Cool. So close. >> Make sure you understand that.
You're embarrassing. There's no morality with you. There's no
grounding values. There's no principles. All you want is attention.
Attention. Attention. Attention. That's all you want. >> Yeah.
Of course you
was caused by the disgusting provocative garbage. another friendly
conversation with another mainstream conservative comment about
how you're such a leftist but those people on Twitter are so
mean. >> Having having a debate or dialogue doesn't automatically
mean that you agree with everything they have to say. It means
you're >> No, it's when you sit down and you exchanging
ideas and debating them to >> No, no, no. I don't agree
with everything they have to say. What are you talking about?
I don't agree with everything they have to say. But, you know,
I'm going to go sit down. >> She uh Uhoh. Oh, is she going
to say, "I don't agree with everything they have to say, but
I don't have to like make every single thing the last helicopter
out of Saigon." Yeah, it could be. >> Sit down and have
a mature debate or >> You have no disagreements about anything
on the right. Yeah, that's called >> I do have criticisms
for the left. I have tons of criticisms for the right. Tons of
criticisms. I'm obviously >> don't seem to come out much
when you're talking to your obviously have a huge problem with
the unending
>> Oh. Oh, you're just going to You're just going to point
out how I'm like lying about you? Oh. Oh, here it comes. Here
it comes. Oh, you're just going to list off all of your like
progressive left positions and and make me look like a total
liar? H, here it comes. Here it come. Why won't people just let
me lie? Both and listen, Andrew and Wilson or sorry, Andrew Wilson
and Desty could be on the same page there, okay? Why won't this
just let me lie about her? Why won't this just let me lie about
her? What the [__] Just let me lie. >> Unmitigated
support for Israel regardless of the genocide they're engaging
in. I have all sorts of disagreements with the right. That doesn't
mean I'm going to dehumanize them and cheer on the slaughter
of my fellow Americans because we have disagreements on politics.
You're >> I wish anybody here had the same energy for the
president of the United States. But that's good. I'm glad you
guys are focused where it really counts on Twitter conservatives
want to be focused on. You know, you are like the prototype of
unbelievable. Oh,
>> that's how uh every DJer gets to discount this entire
conversation. Oh no, she she said he has TDS. She's saying Trump
isn't a problem. Oh, >> you wake up every morning and you
decide your behavior is going to hinge on >> Tell me more
about Israelis and building
all knew about 911 want to go to war.
>> She's just trying is He's just trying to call her an
anti-Semite now.
Actually, I'm just going to call you an anti. Actually, you're
just anti-Semitic. He's like He's hoping that line will work.
Okay, guess what? That line ain't working so well anymore. Okay,
let me bring you one.
Not once. Don't make things up, you disgusting prick. >> Let
me bring in Jack again. Let me bring in Jack again. Jack Peter
Navaro ear >> Why won't you just let me lie about you?
Why won't Just let me lie. Anna >> was talking about directly
to Elon Musk about in his view uh the urgent need for Elon Musk
to detoxify
X given that he owns a platform and that he blamed X for a lot
of the toxicity in in public discourse. What What do you feel
about that? Well, you know, I I I think there's obviously a tension
between um you know, stand standing and wanting free dialogue
and freedom of speech, but also maintaining a line beyond uh
calling for violence and calling for direct um direct violence
or direct criminal activity. So, you know, X in its original
Twitter fashion, if you go all the way back to uh, you know,
2012, 2010 when when it was really getting going, they used to
pretty much pretty much the the main things that were banned
uh or would get get taken down or get accounts banned were posting
of direct um uh addresses of people, so doxing or uh posting
or posting direct threats to violence. And so I I think there
needs to be that mindset of this is uh acceptable discourse.
This is a a back and forth, but the idea that a direct call for
violence uh should be banned, I think that's something that I
would support.
>> Andrew, what do you feel about the social media aspect
of all this? Do you think that it is culpable to a degree in
uh the surging text toxicity of of debate about these things?
Look, uh, social media is a tool and what that what social media
has done right now is it's allowed us to get a glimpse into leftist
ideology finally and we get to see the insane madness that was
always there. And uh, the fact of the matter is is that, you
know, here on the panel right this second, you have a guy who
celebrated a multitude of these types of things, including telling
his co-host that uh, that basically Trump the worst place that
the assassin could have put the bullet was anywhere other than
Trump. I mean, I got the clip of him doing it. And so the thing
is is like what we've noted now, these people are glad. They're
glad. They're happy. They love it. I go on TikTok all the time
and I debate with these people. It's very clear that leftists
are glad that this happened and that they're going to do everything
they can to promote more of it. And we're supposed to base our
behavior on what the president does or doesn't say. What? Like
if if if Biden if I had Biden derangement syndrome, I couldn't
still come out and condemn political violence. Of course I could.
But the thing is >> I'm just curious. Anybody have any
words for the fact that Charlie said that Biden should collective
leftist collectively can't >> Oh, weak point seem to do
that though. I I don't know why they can't seem to do >> No,
that was fine when Charlie Kirk said I know. I want to mention
something to you which I wasn't going to talk to. >> Charlie
Kirk was a moderate. He was more
>> than a local.
>> He was more moderate than a local electrician. And you
know that he wanted he said he wanted to see Biden he wanted
to see with the worst he said he wanted to see Biden executed.
Okay. Give me a
performance. He said if you violate performative criminality
in criminal law performative out
>> uh president doesn't matter in terms of disavowing violence.
President matters in like so many ways. President doesn't matter
in terms of saying yeah I obviously think you can't like I obviously
disavow Charlie Kirk being shot. I obviously disavow political
violence. Um, and trying to withhold that to extract some concession
from the other side is just insane. And you look awful. And they
will farm you forever and never answer any of your questions
in any kind of good faith. They'll just farm you and make you
look stupid farming the end of your career because
that's what's best for them. It's obvious. It's obvious it it
it matters. Sorry. It's obvious that that's what they'll do.
You think it doesn't matter? I don't think it matters. I don't
I don't think you can ever go you can never say, "Oh my god,
people are so
every single person here. So, Nemo, I I might have to reiterate
this the same point, okay, for all these people. You cannot evaluate
how much these people care about Trump. You can't evaluate it
from this panel. They will all farm Destiny being a totally deranged
mutant instead of actually answering any of his questions. They'll
just keep farming him being a deranged mutant for as long as
they possibly can, continuing to get money from him from all
the people who are like, "Oh, that's kind of gross. I don't like
that." They'll continue to make him look like an unhinged
like a what would you call it? Like totem of the liberal establishment
of the leftist establishment in the United States, right? Like
they'll just continue to farm him. >> Every person every
person benefits from him being an idiot on this panel, right?
Cuz Anna got so much for leaving the left or whatever it's called.
Um and he's helping he helps her completely by continuing to
perform this way. Yeah. >> To act this way, to like have
these standards. Yeah.
>> Yeah. And like, but a lot of people are like, "Oh, like
we're supposed to act like it doesn't matter what the president
says." You're not never going to get that out of this panel.
You won't be able to get it unless you disavow the violence,
right? You have to disavow the violence and then say, "But also,
can we talk about Trump a little bit and then go back to disavowing
the violence? You just can't." And they'll make you look as unhinged
as they want this whole time. They'll never ever engage with
you in good faith. You'll look insane. You'll make your movement
look insane. you'll be. But this is the exact same thing. This
is why we said, this is why I said go watch Pisco if you want
political takes because he's going to put the movement above
himself, above his ego. Destiny will never do that. He cannot
put his movement above his ego. He will always hurt his movement
for his own moment. >> Yes, that is true. >> Don't
do it to him. >> No, I'm going to do it. I'm going to do
it to both of them. Pisco and Josiah sometimes have like really
far-left beliefs, and they do bite a lot of those terrible bullets
that you should not
>> Okay. I thought you were going to say that Pisco is
really bad at talking [__]
>> I I I watch >> that goes without saying. Why do
I I don't have to continuously say that. >> I watched Aaron
skull like sorry not uh curb stomp curb stomp pisco like on his
own stream on his own stream. All right. Over his sense of humor.
>> No. Okay. Listen, I will I will throw shots and stuff
like that, but some moments are just so funny that when you're
so bad at talking, when you're so bad at having a contentious
conversation with somebody that you don't want to just bury,
when he out of nowhere was just like, "Hold on, let me finish."
And she didn't cut him off. I thought that was amazing. That
was my favorite Pisco
>> That is a fantastic Pisco moment. He cuts her off and
then she lets him talk and then he's like, "But hold on, let
me finish going." Absolutely no input from her. She's like, "I
didn't cut I didn't do anything." >> That's going around
recently that people imagining getting cut off. There's a lot
of that going around.
>> See, in a couple different places. Yeah. See, where
were we here?
>> He said if you violate performative criminality in criminal
law, >> then that will be the case. >> I want to
What's performative? What's performative? So if I say so I >> Oh,
hold on. Uh Porter wants to know, Cherry, what far-left belief
does Pisco
>> That Biden is the best president of his
>> I think Yeah, I think that was silly, but I uh >> Exactly.
It was silly. I No, it is a far-left belief to imagine that you
have to support this corpse that was running for another term
to the point where you gaslight everyone and say, "Oh, he's the
best president of my lifetime. That's why I would go for a second
term despite not knowing who the has been running. >> Yeah.
I mean, if I had to pick an example, it wouldn't be that one.
It would be the uh >> Anybody who does blue no matter who?
That is too far left for me. You're not willing to be critical
of your movement? I I don't know. That's too far left for >> Yeah.
Everybody in the chat is going to differentiate and say that's
um that's like centrist um like blue no matter who is not like
a leftist movement. They're going to use left as like socialist,
not uh not
not like Democrat establishment aligned. You're saying like extreme
like like extremely centrist or something or like extremely like
>> Democrat partisan. He's super partisan. >> Yeah.
Yeah. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> Um I would say though that
Pisco Okay. Pisco is No, I I think I know what you mean, but
um just figured I'd ask the >> I don't use those words
correctly, so it's fine if people in chat are like, "She doesn't
know what a leftist is." >> Yeah. Porter is not a though,
so he he understands. He gets it. Um, but also if you want leftist
beliefs, look no further than Pisco. Pisco is like a hardcore
leftist on Palestine. Okay? Pisco is like a 100% behind every
BDS law that's ever been made. Okay? Pisco is like down with
Israel. Down with
So if you want a leftist belief, that's what he's got. Anyway,
>> continuing. I don't know. I I suspect kind of, but I
actually I'm just mostly making that up. performative. >> I
also have to open my windows. Sorry, give me a second, guys.
>> In criminal law, performative, >> then that will
be the case. I want to
performative performance. >> Wait, so if I say so I say,
oh, well, you know, I think that guy was a criminal, therefore
the execution is okay. Somehow that makes everything fine with
no investigation, no criminal
opponent should be in jail, highest extent of the line. What
are you talking about? Sorry. No, that's not >> saying
the word performative doesn't mean anything. >> The National
Guard right now investigations into
I want to bring Anna back.
I want to bring Anna back in >> Okay. I want to bring Anna
back in because the president-elect of the Oxford Union, the
probably the most premier debating society in the world. I've
done it several times myself. George Abber on Aberon. >> Destiny
is wrong. Wait, what did he just say? I missed that. I was opening
the window and >> that will be the case. I want to ask
there's not what's performative what's performative. >> So
if I say so if I say oh well you know I think that guy was a
criminal therefore the execution is okay somehow that makes everything
fine with no investigation no charges all the time your political
opponent should be in jail highest extent of the line. What are
you talking about? Sorry, that's >> saying the word performative
doesn't mean anything. >> The National Guard right now
investigations into >> That's just performative. I want
to bring Anna back.
I want to bring back performative. >> Okay. I want to bring
Anna back in because the president-elect of the >> I would
say that if they were going over, if they're going back and forth
of the Charlie Kirk like Biden execution thing, I'd say that's
like basically I don't know what Destiny would get uh like upset
with there. That's the exact kind of thing that Charlie Kirk
would use or sorry that Destiny would use as like Am Bailey to
bait people into talking with him, right? He'd say this guy needs
this guy needs to be, you know, he needs to be jailed or if if
the laws say so like publicly executed or something like that
and he he'd hinge on like the people not hearing like the part
that sort of like couches it slightly and he's going to hinge
on like uh people only hearing the extreme part and coming to
argue with him, right? >> Union, the probably the most
premier debating society in the world. Uh but sniff is the it's
the death sentence. He deserves the death sentence or or like
a public execution with a death sentence.
>> Ban that guy. >> What do I say butt sniffer? >> I
didn't I didn't ban him. I uh I muted him from the chat so chat
doesn't see him anymore. The onream chat. They don't see him
anymore. >> I've done it several times myself. George Abber
on Abberon
reportedly posted uh several he didn't reported. He did post
several comments in a WhatsApp group appearing to celebrate the
murder of Charlie Kirk. One said, "Charlie Kirk got shot. Let's
go." Another one was, I think, LOL.
>> Let's go.
Let's go. >> Um, this guy is going to be the president
of the Oxford Union debate. >> That That's I'm just imitating
how Pierce should have read that. I don't actually think that
about um I don't actually think that about Charlie. And yet he
is celebrating the murder of somebody he literally debated himself
in the Oxford Union in May. I found that terrifying.
I I mean he shouldn't still be on the job because how can you
possibly be the head of a debating society when you think the
way to debate with people is is murder them if they don't agree
with you. But again, the gleeful celebration.
This is supposedly one of the brightest students in Britain.
You know, president of the new Oxford Union Debate Society. >> He
can't be that bright if he's not considering what a political
assassination could potentially lead to because where does this
end?
>> And that's like one of my biggest issues with a portion
of the left, their inability to see past the current moment,
right? you're celebrating it, but what's what's the long-term
goal here? Is the long-term goal to just kind of descend to an
environment of endless political assassinations and violence?
And um if we're going to have the left go up against the right
in >> sounds like content for a lot of these people to
be honest, >> in terms of violence, in terms of bloodshed,
in terms of shootings, >> uh that's that's the peers. That's
actually Anakasparian setup that's doing that artifacting that
like that choppiness. That's anarchist barian >> I don't
know. I would just venture to say that the right is probably
going to do a better job in, you know, taking people out than
the left is. >> This is just a really disgusting sick ideology
and we need to move away from it. And again, I want to emphasize
>> your personal behavior. The way you choose to behave
and respond to things on a day-to-day basis has an impact. Okay?
Be the change you want to see in the world. So when you have
a huge audience and that audience of young people who look up
to you, who feel inspired by you hear you essentially minimize
political violence or even make >> No, she Anna doesn't
understand. It's actually only bad when Hassan does that. It's
super awesome when Desi does it. It's only bad. It's only a problem
when Hassan does it. Okay, I she's just confused. I think I understand
>> for it or deflect by blaming Trump for everything. Well,
you're essentially indoctrinating people to support and normalize
political violence. We can't be doing that. I don't care how
people behave on the right. That's not going to have an impact
on how I personally choose to behave. I want to be better than
that. I want to preach dialogue, okay? Debate, have these conversations.
And you know, Charlie Kirk, the last debate he and I had, you
know, Dusty would like you to believe that I agree with the right
on everything. I don't agree with the right on everything. We
debated about whether or not you have to have children in order
to care about the future of this country. >> So, we have
a debate and it's fine. He has a right to his opinions. I have
the right to mine. If you care about democracy, the democratic
process is reliant on having these types of conversations and
reliant on not resorting to violence because you're unable to
articulate your arguments effectively against the other side.
That's what I see this assassination as. Again, it was cowardice.
It was disgusting. It was cold-blooded murder. And no one should
be celebrating it. And no one should be mocking the family members
of Charlie Kirk. >> Yeah. O. It's like just I just I can't
help but see it. Okay. It's just like setting in for this guy
that he uh he got cooked and he's uh he's just thinking about
all the people who are going to watch this and like kind of laugh
at him. I >> Very well said. Just want to thank Jack, I
want to sort of say to you, I can tell by your demeanor today
how profoundly impacted you've been >> by your friends
and I'm just very sorry to you >> as his friends.
>> It's shut up. >> Was that Andrew? >> That
was Andrew. Yeah. Um he's he calls him, but um sorry. I find
it funny. I just find it I find it more funny than that is just
like Destiny's total aversion to any human moment. Like anything
that is human is just like so offputting to him that he has to
feel disgust at it. Like actual disgusting things, no. No. He'll
watch like gore and a bunch of other gross. But human moments
like other people like feeling empathy for people feeling empathy
for others. Those like disgust him viscerally. It's like a visceral
disgust he feels every time he sees it.
>> Relieved to see any heat come from Andrew at least.
>> Yeah. Even if it's as juvenile as uh
>> endure what must have been a hellish week and >> actual
ghouls. >> I'd like to send my very best to the family
who I know you talked to and I'm sorry for some of the things.
>> Well, I I don't know where that comes from. Actual ghouls
who >> you've had to hear from Destiny in this debate.
Uh but thank you for coming on despite what you've been going
through. So I appreciate it. >> Thank you Piers. I'll I'll
convey that to them. >> Thank you very much. Thank you
to the panel. Thank you. Persson is proudly independent. The
only boss around here is me. If you enjoy our show, we ask for
only one. >> All right. All right. Thanks for the show,
Pierce. That was good.
>> That is Sneo. That was Sneo and Kanye when they came
on in Italy, I think. No, Portugal. I think they're in Portugal,
right here. Must have been a sick place they're at. Don't take
inches off my pears. My name's Yay. I got I got 6 million followers
or whatever. Yeah. Yeah, that was a good one. All right, so from
there, uh, we're looking around a little bit more. I think this
was even before Destiny, sorry, after Destiny got invited on
this. Okay, we had a bunch of [__] going on. We had
um is it Alex Jones decided to tweet this out? Got 370,000 views.
Steven Bedell aka Desty calls for the conservatives to be more
often so they will be afraid to attend events or speak out. This
is the literal definition of terrorism. Wait, did he just copy
the right angle news guy? Bro, that's kind of [__]
up to like copy his text almost exactly. >> dude. He actually
just copied it entirely. That's crazy. Someone's someone's lazy
as Alex Jones's operation. He copied the clip one to one, didn't
psych the guy, and copied the the original text. The Trump might
actually arrest Destiny. Well, certainly I feel like Listen,
that FBI is kind of corrupt right now. We should nudge him towards
looking at some hard drives. That's all I'm saying. Okay, whoever's
watching, whoever's watching that, >> it's being Wait,
it Cash Patel, that's an Indian, right?
>> Yeah. You worried? >> Maybe they're safe.
That was one of them. I thought you said they're all the all
the people left are the it >> the IT.
>> You know what? What's the next segment? Where are we
going? >> What is the next segment? Um, there's some Tim
Pool stuff on this. There's some Tim Pool stuff. There's >> a
Candace Owens segment that I think is going to be good. Okay.
>> Fentes went live almost 100K. I mean, he's pretty bought
it. He's probably like doubled up.
It could be. It could be like quadrupled, but I don't know. Are
we going to cover this? Was this Nick versus Assad? We cover
this right off the bat. We're trying to see. Let's see here.
I have a rumble answering the questions. Who Charlie Kurt, Israel,
gropers or leftists? Oh, we could go cover this. Damn. Could
go cover some of that at some point. I was just going to cover
this stuff right now. That could also be content tomorrow. We'll
see. Um, what do we have? Oh, the Tim Pool tweet. Hold on. We
got Tim Pool going in here. What did Tim Pool have to say? Charlie
Kirk was a moderate if he was worthy of death to the left. What
does that say for everyone else? Tim, as someone who's debated
all these people, like Destiny, many times, I'd love to come
back on your show to talk about this. Okay. All right. I'll I'll
like it, but